all right
who's is that not mine that's my
scrunchie what about this one
stop darn my scrunchies those are
expensive at the mall
don't put them in my space
all right it's time for us on good for
you to talk about the hard
hitting news that's what you come to
this podcast for
right poor usual i will address the
hottest breaking news
the second it breaks this is hardly
broken this news
i don't even think it's fully broken yet
i'm broken we're gonna
we're gonna finish the breaking right
now it is time to talk about britney's
testimony and i know i know what you're
thinking i'm not always the fastest
when it comes to talking about current
events but i like to think through
things
i like to mull it over listen to it
process it
have a thoughtful take i think if you
guys know anything about me at this
point
it's that i like to think before i speak
that's what i always say about you i
like to wait and really think about what
i'm going to say before i
say it i'm not just going to yell things
out willy-nilly
like for the moment to pass right on
back you're on good for you
you may not get the fastest takes but
you will get the hottest
and the most mindful so here's my
thought or two
i heard the recording of brittany's
testimony
i believe that britney's 25-minute
is more coherent than half of the media
i consume
on average and what scares me is i don't
think any of us
have heard anyone talk that sanely with
that much composure
for 25 minutes straight in at least five
years
so i don't think any of us really knew
what we were even hearing because we
have no reference point
for sanity anymore i i i'm gonna be
honest with you
i don't think half of the people who
heard this even knew what to make of it
because she sounded saner than 99 of the
conversations i've seen on twitter
today half the people i know could not
talk for 25 minutes straight
recorded uninterrupted without
eventually
alluding to something like the vaccine
has a chip in it
or the that donald trump is still
technically president or some iteration
of tom hanks
like being a lizard i don't even know
if you guys understand how weird it was
to hear someone talk
that sanely for that long what i have
seen
other celebrities not under a
conservatorship
do in the past year or so is way more
insane than whatever
she has done what about the 40
celebrities right now who are currently
doing ig lives where they say that
they're making space for difficult
conversations where only they get to
talk
and the whole time they're on their ig
live and they're just like hey
hey oh my god i'm brazil
i love you
where did she hold on is that you
lindsay
are you there as if the person joining
can hear you are you there
are you there it's been a year why do
you guys know how to use ig live yet
what's going on
how is that more sane than what britney
is doing she's way more coherent than
any celebrity i've seen speak
in months okay the celebrities that
aren't in a conservatorship you know
what they're doing
they're all making incoherent podcasts
listen to 25 minutes
of any celebrity podcast and they will
make what britney just did for 25
minutes sound like beowulf
and if you don't know what beowulf is i
don't respect your opinion anyway
i just i feel like what's happening is
they've forgotten
what they were mad about you know when
you're like in a fight and you're like i
i can't even remember what i was mad
about but i've been mad for so long and
i'm so invested in being mad that i
can't
change my mind now but to be clear like
what she did
from my recollection is she hit a car
with an umbrella
not anyone's best night but i like us
just to rethink
that whole situation because i didn't
have a podcast when this happened when
did this happen
2007 2007. i didn't have a podcast i
didn't have a platform
if i had at the time i would have come
to her defense and i would have said
the fact that britney even had an
umbrella at
all if it never rains in la if you have
an umbrella in los angeles that means
you are the most
uh thoughtful responsible person in this
state i'm gonna go as far as to say i
believe she should get custody of her
kids back
right now today solely based on the fact
that she had an umbrella with her in
california
that one time three years after she
shaved her head lady gaga wore a meat
dress
and i loved lady gaga me too but
journalists were coming after brittany
and
they were saying she had a mental
illness for wearing a crocheted top
and bad taste is not a mental illness
it's just a burden
not one that you carry like i can't
carry other ones i feel like
i have a lot of other ones as someone
that has bad taste
yeah someone
do not speak for me do not silence me
and someone who has my own bad case
they also like the fact that they got
mad at her
for hitting a car window with an
umbrella like there was like it was like
a spur of the moment like
fit of emotion i fully carry
a glass cutter and a full hammer in my
car
at all times for driving around parking
lots
just hoping someone left their dog in a
hot car like hers was spontaneous mine
is like
plant i have weapons in my car
hoping to shatter someone's window the
way britney frankly
didn't okay wha why why why do i get to
be here
i drive around the target lot
just looking just waiting you're a
vigilante
truly an umbrella it's child's play
i think people decided she was super
crazy when she shaved her head and i
would
again i would like to address this
because i did not have a podcast
or show at the time because when this
all happened women weren't allowed on tv
so i'm now going to tell you what i
believe
i believe that the shaving the head
thing was not that crazy
i i believe that the sanest thing any
woman can do
is shave her head we have we have we
have you know what it is
we have backwards in our culture what's
sane
and what's crazy for her to shave her
head
at that point was way saner than what
she was doing before so you're saying
like oh you shaved your head you must be
crazy
you know what's crazy another woman
shaving her head
and brittany paying her money for the
hair
and then someone sewing it into a little
clip and then putting it into her hair
under the hair she does have and trying
to make it blend in
as if it's her own hair and then they
curl
someone else's hair up on her head like
she's a little doll
and they just go peekaboo i have new
hair now even though i had this short
hair yesterday
now i have three feet of hair and we're
all just gonna pretend it's mine
that that's the premise of every horror
movie that i like
how is shaving your head saner shaving
your head as a woman is a solution
let's be honest if i had shaved my head
six months ago y'all would
think i went sane
the sanest thing i could do right now is
shave my head i also do think don't you
think the people kind of
people didn't like the head shaving
thing with her also because they she did
it herself
oh yeah they wanted her they needed her
to pay for it don't you think
that's my theory my theory is she went
and she shaded her she's like why would
i pay you to do it i know how to do this
like she's just like a functioning
person she's like i'm not going to
overpay this
random person to shave my head i'll just
do it myself they're closing i'm going
to be polite
i'm not going to walk into this this
hair cuttery and be like i'm putting
spears shaving my head she's like no no
i got it she was polite to the staff
i'm happy to do it myself i'm having a
rough time i just need to shave my head
brb and she handled it if some
professional hair person
that has like a hundred thousand
followers on instagram did her hair
and like shaved it perfectly everyone
would be like slay
punk rock yes they totally would oh what
if she shaved her head
i mean if she did that today we'd just
be like well she's transitioning into a
happy relationship where she cancels
people on twitter
this is her new lifestyle she's gonna
get a septum piercing and be angry for
no reason
um you know what it is she would get a
comeback she would have she would have
such a comeback she would get on the new
gossip girl
[Laughter]
if you shave your head now you literally
get to be on every float
yeah you get every l'oreal campaign you
champion global warming
you get to have your own like hbo max
series you get to have a sketchup
you get to be mad at other people's
water bottles
i just here's what it is here's what now
that we're looking back
birds eye view and as someone who is not
super close to this
situation this entire time i can tell
you that
what she did was she committed the two
cardinal sins
that men will never forgive and that's
what she didn't commit the worst sins
she's
committed the worst sins in the eyes of
a man
she scratched a car and she cut her hair
those are two things that men do not let
slide here's the other thing is that now
the next step is they're probably going
to have
some by the way please notice the fact
that i am only using one hand
it's because i have severed my finger
over the weekend and i have a bandage on
it that looks like a cartoon like civil
war
like tourniquet i thought you were the
host to pimp my rock
but no and so as i'm making a case that
someone's not crazy
i can't like have this fucking bandage
on my thumb let me tell you why she's
not
so i'm trying to be like hide it which
is even
crazier this is my biggest concern my
biggest concern is now she's gonna have
like a new evaluator come in a new
psychiatrist come in and sit down and
talk to her and evaluate
whether she's mentally fit that
testimony makes me think she's 100
mentally fit i don't know what more
information you need
but i just want you guys to know that if
you talk to her
it is going to be a weird conversation
like she's going to be weird that
doesn't mean she's mentally ill
if she is that's not my business but i'm
just saying like she hasn't spoken to
anyone she's she's
socially awkward she's rusty the last
conversation she had was with bjork
swann
backstage at wango tango in
2008 i mean there's a difference between
being crazy and just
having the conversations all pop stars
have had that was probably the last
person that really
listened to her it's also like she has
no one to talk to she has no one to
practice her conversation skills like
who's she going to talk
to she hasn't had like friends since the
disney show i feel like she's like
doesn't know what to do because what
disney show was she
wasn't she a disney a disney rocker
the mickey mouse club yes
she was 12. she was on the disney show
she was a disney um
lady yeah she was a basketeer she was a
cheerleader for the disney sports
i know ryan gosling where are you ryan
gosling
i have already dealt with the fact that
you're never going to date me so i'm
going to come for you right now why are
you helping her i saw what you did
in the movie drive i know you can get
away with someone in a car
your whole life has been preparing for
this moment
now you agree that ryan should handle
this i thought lala land why not
but here's the other thing if anyone can
tap dance over cars
get her away why can't you just uh
dazzle jamie with your talents
look over here and jamie go now that's a
star
and totally just forget about you send
you out to pastor
the arguments against it are there's
something we don't know obviously there
was something terrible that happened
that we didn't see that we didn't
witness she's a danger to herself to the
kids or whatever we haven't heard
a lot but they do like to throw up that
picture of her driving with her
baby on her lap or her kid on her lap
i'm not defending that i'm just saying
all every parent i know did that when i
was a kid it doesn't get me in trouble
but we used to sit in the back of pickup
trucks
where we put like trash bags down
in in like fancy place mats and
what are the things that cover tables
tablecloths that were shiny on top
and we would put a hose in it and make
it a pool
and then drive on the interstate
so i that is i do think they're being a
little hard on her cause she's a little
country
i mean that is in my hometown babies are
having babies and we're putting them on
bush hogs
and the babies are bush in the fields i
didn't see a bush hog in that photo
no our babies could travel john deere's
our babies are mowing lawns john does
yes our babies are babies in the south
they have jobs they chain smoke those
babies are fine
i'm just saying we've all done crazy
shit yeah i mean we love they also love
to throw that picture of her eating
cheetos barefoot in that bath public
bathroom
at a rest stop you know they're like
she's crazy listen
if he and cheetos barefoot in a bathroom
makes you crazy lock me up sister
because i'm unstable i will put chicken
nuggets in my pants to sneak them in a
movie theater don't don't
we're fucked
it feels too severe that's all i'm
saying even if she did do something
gnarly
this does feel like too much i feel like
no matter what danger she put her
child in she put herself in nobody
deserves
to live in calabasas for 13 years
now i know a lot about this case but
what i do know
is that she is the best mom in calabasas
if you want to lock someone up in
calabasas i am available
i um again if if if you
if all conservative ships end up in
calabasas i do have time
and i can be a lot weirder let me let me
tell you something because i was getting
a petition to jamie like hey jamie
if you know him personally yes
look at yourself in the mirror jamie
jamie lynn what is that jamie
jamilyn spears his sister but what's
jamie's name
what's jamie's full name jamie what's
his middle name i'd like to address him
formally
as if i was in court yeah james jamie
diablo spears what kind of adult man is
named jamie first of all
love you jamie from rogue jamie phone uh
i want to make a deal with jamie which
is this
if you look in the mirror and you just
look at yourself and you go you know
what the fuck are you doing man
this is your daughter i made a mistake
turns out
my kink is just keeping sad girls locked
up in my basement
we can help you with that let brittany
go
and if you just need sad people in your
basement that you give a five thousand
dollar a week
uh spending on clothes allowance and you
just need us to
work out and dance like go to any mall
in america
i volunteer as tribute let her free
take me volunteers tribute
i'm just saying michael jackson hung his
baby out of a hotel room window
ozzy osbourne used to famously bite
heads off of live
birds in business meetings and people
just thought it was cool and funny guys
do crazy shit and they just get to keep
working
yeah war if i wear a shirt with a bird
on it it's like bird lady you're
crazy bird lady
and both those things are true that is
the one print i don't have
is birds what's the problem here
so now the point of this whole
video i would like to speak directly to
the people
that are in the home of britney spears
who are paid to help
keep her in there and keep this
nightmare haunted house running
yes i assume they're all big fans of our
podcast for some reason but this is
going to get to one of you i know one of
you is watching this i know
even if it's like the legal surveillance
department down in the basement that
they hire to just like
like scan the internet for dangerous
people i want to be on that list
i want to be printed out in the garage
like do not let her in
i just want you guys to hear this there
is a dynamic sometimes that happens
when you have done a bad thing and
you've done a tisk tisk
where you feel like you've done it for
so long that you can't turn back now
maybe it's stockholm syndrome maybe it's
just you want to double down on your bad
decision so you don't feel guilt from
before
you might think too much time has passed
for you to possibly ever
rectify this wrong i'm here to tell you
the perfect amount of time has passed
and today's the day today's the day for
you to be a snitch
we're here to tell you that now is the
time to snitch
for a good cause and i know you're
thinking you're scared of the
non-disclosure agreement the nda a lot
of people have
come to talk to the press but they say
they can't share anything because of an
nda
let me demystify the elusive
enigma that is the hollywood nda
i have a pen i want to take notes i
thought you didn't sign one
mine is very loose most ndas are
basically saying
hey please don't tell anyone where i
live or what my phone number is and when
you leave the job
can you not tell anyone what where my
mom's nursing home is this is an nda
that probably threatens them that if
they speak anything about the details
that they have seen
that they will be sued for all the money
they have put a lien on their house
that's not legally possible it's fake
it's not real most ndas there's a
usually like a 5 000 violation fee
if they even decide to charge you with
it right so if someone comes on this
podcast
from the brittany you know um empire
pool house yeah i don't know
i feel like we're gonna get the pool guy
for some reason
i just feel it i don't feel like we're
getting the house manager on
i'm just saying they're going to be
worried like i'm violating this thing
first of all if you come on my show
they sue me because i own your footage
so they can't even sue you personally
bam uh you're welcome wait why am i
encouraging myself to get sued this is
bad
this is going in the wrong direction but
it's very rare that if you violate an
nda people are going to come
after you because they would have to sue
you there would be a jury there'd be a
judge it would take a year to get a
court date let's be honest with the
britney spears thing i have a feeling
the jury
would be on your side okay
so ndas are not as scary as they seem
there might be a little financial fee
you're worried about you might you might
not get your next job
i'm just telling you guys that if you do
decide to snitch
i want to let you know that good for you
is going to cover those legal fees
finally got a job working for your idol
but now you just put duct tape over her
mouth
we're here to help if you've worked with
brittany during her conservatorship but
aren't sure what to do
because you signed a stupid nda donald
ndas
email us now please do not call us you
can tell us
any information anonymously and if jamie
tries to sue you
he's gonna have to answer to me and
nobody wants to do that
we will cover all your legal fees no
questions asked how many questions are
asked ben 10
a few but just a little bit no questions
just enough to the lawyer understand
what's going on what's the company say
you can't they they're they're not gonna
leave if they're like oh deal with
no questions just so you know
here good for you we will give you the
cash you need to be the snitch
britney deserves finally got a job
working for your idol but now all you do
is put duct tape over her mouth we're
here to help
here to help we're here to help you
if you've been working for brittany this
is
there's no there's no rhyme to this
jingle who is the nick from the
handmaid's tale
of this situation it's britney spears
isn't everyone just falling in love with
her being like babe i gotta get you out
of here that's every guy's dream is to
be able to like
get a princess out of the castle this is
more like a swim fan situation
i guess what i'm saying is that if you
want to be the nick of this situation
i'm going to take care of that nda
violation then you're going to
come over to my place you're going to
slip me one of britney spears's
handwritten notes
you know what i'm going to do with that
i'm then going to take it over to miley
cyrus i will be wearing a cape
and then she is gonna come in on a
wrecking ball
don't you feel like celebrities have the
power to fix this not me but don't you
think i just think if celebrities
stormed
that house it would be over if they had
their cameras out
they're very busy if i if they they're
everyone's on stage going like support
brady's forever
just go to her house you know you at the
time i've seen your instagram you have
go over there with you the foot this is
what i do with zoos and
go with the camera what do they do shoot
you what are they going to do shoot
adele if adele's like i'd like if
madonna you know what this is this is
this is a job for madonna if madonna
went to britney spears's home and let's
say jamie wasn't there because he's
dealing with a legal nightmare
also known as whitney hummings um
if madonna showed up at the house anyone
that worked there if madonna was like
hey like
i'm here to take brittany like on a walk
like her dad said it was okay we're just
gonna kind of like talk like sort of
about the business
and how hard it is and it's just sort of
like you don't think someone would let
her leave with madonna
tell me i don't i do and i know why you
do because that's how you enter spaces
like i'm taking all of you with me and
everyone now is with me
and this building is now my building
that's how you enter spaces but
you don't think madonna walks into
spaces like that no i think people
they're like that's what they are she's
already in the face so she'll walk in
that space
but she won't you don't know how jobs
work she might have to go outside at
some point
these people are being paid to not let
her leave
i understand but if madonna showed up i
can see someone that works there doing a
great job
no blame at you having jamie come home
going where's britney oh madonna took
her on the drive to talk about the
business that you authorized and she he
go i never authorized that you're never
supposed to let her leave
but it was madonna but you think there
should be a separate clause
madonna shows up jamie's thought through
this and he hired no gays
so now there you go that's why
so now they're like they're like who is
this woman who is this lady
they're like we gotta keep this lady in
here this lady can't come in here who
all these ladies were keeping i thought
it was a good idea if madonna came
in they'd be like look we knew she
couldn't leave with stephen dorf but you
didn't specify that she couldn't leave
with madonna
he said i'm here for brittany yes it
feels like a different
situation i don't know i don't i think
the boyfriend is of no help
i i i think you seem very lovely sir uh
and emily's available uh if you need a
rebound i'm just saying
i don't feel like the boyfriend
has skin in the game of
getting her out of there because do you
really think britney spears would date
him if she was allowed to dm
channing tatum whenever she wanted to if
she gets out is she staying with him
uh well she you know a big selling point
of her
conversation with the judge that she
wants to ride in his fucking car so
i mean so she can go straight to the
t-mobile store and get jenny james
i think she has she can bring it i like
that says t-mobile in this situation i
don't know
t-mobile's story is the funniest
reference and you know that
that's all they give her money for i'm
just saying like
if i'm him i'm psyched like you don't
take her out to dinner
you can you have every excuse in the
book to be like look i would have called
but
i was i was in the second floor and i
can't come to the third floor
they won't let me the armed guard i just
feel like he's psyched he doesn't have
to do like chivalry shit he doesn't have
to spend money on her
and she only wears peasant tops from the
90s it's like every guy's dream of a
girl
i'll just work out and yeah all shows is
work out and wear peasant tops from the
90s it's like his dream
because she is that every guy is into
the print you know what sorry
random theory that i've never been able
to random there i've never been able to
flesh out
we can stop right there yeah is that
you've noticed like guys
are often intimidated by women that make
their own money
no i've never noticed that but they're
infatuated this is why
women that have inherited money like the
women are only allowed to have money if
they didn't like work for
you know why no it's because
it's easier for me to you spend your
money if you also have to work for it
now it's like well you didn't work for
it either bitch
i can buy all the golf courses you got
this on your diddy
and now i'm your diddy and that's the
thought process there you work for money
they're like oh my god she's not gonna
know that i've
taken this money because she's in the
office working
she can balance the checkbook she has an
office
when you have an office they're they're
scared of you when you have an estate
they're like
she won't find me yeah this this says
she hates your dad anyway i'm in the
garden
i just was trying to think of that
because maybe he doesn't think she's
earned all her money because her dad's
like i did all that like this isn't
yours
i don't know i'm going on tangents but
he seems like a very nice instagram
model
anyway i say we all work hard to get
britney spears
out so that y'all can get back to loving
her and being a huge
fan and making her your spirit animal so
that in a couple years you can then try
and cancel her for a tweet she sent
when she was a teenager
when she gets out you know that's gonna
happen five years later we're gonna be
like
did you see that tweet she sent when she
was 14. you know that for a whole year
she couldn't leave her house
hasn't it been 13 years no all of last
year she said she couldn't leave why not
we were a pandemic
got it none of us could leave last year
okay so it's 12 years
it's 12 years okay small footnote see
this is what
two weeks of mulling something over and
doing
hardcore journalism on things like that
you get to the facts it wasn't 13 it was
because of the pandemic yeah so what did
she complain about 12 years that's what
i'm going to say
when she's ever like i was there for 13
years it was 12. we were all
we were all in prison for that yeah 12
years of slaves so bad
no you can say it i didn't
um uh this interview that is coming up
whew i'm late for my therapy call what a
shocker she's
you know what when i tell her why she's
gonna be like oh well that's fine
you just talked for two hours about how
britney spears isn't crazy that's why
you're late to this therapy call
first of all we do we should wrap this
up by saying that
uh she's not crazy we do support her
crazy's a word that's just you should
take that iud out how dare you make her
wear an iud
an explosive inside of her that's crazy
i really want to know if it's the metal
one or the
it's probably a tracking device that's i
the only thing i want to say to that is
like they make me wear an id i want to
be like
that's what they told you it was and now
you d tom tom
is it around your neck that's not where
iuds go
is it blinking yeah like uh is it around
your ankle vibrating like that's not an
iud
just fyi that's a walkie-talkie um
that's an explosive duct tape to your
body but here are good for you we want
to free brittany free brittany
period period so that's never going to
happen until she's free we're ending
every episode because instead of don't
worry elephants
don't ride brittany her dad don't don't
don't
but no i think for me it's more it's
more like every couple episodes once a
month that will take on one big topic
and just really no i think for me what
it is
maybe a couple more episodes we'll take
another topic yeah for me we're gonna
start
doing that and then send us ideas for
a hundredth episode of the podcast send
us ideas for other people to free
yeah i know everyone's gonna oh really
but this person who's wrongfully
imprisoned for 50 years you're not going
to do it and what's their name
they'll still tell us i'm sure there's
something wrong with everything we just
said
i have some announcements what do you
want me to tell you so
let's get right into them reno nevada
she's going to be there july 23rd at the
grand sierra resort with taylor
tomlinson i think i'm also going to be
there
one night only also viva las vegas
august 7th she'll be at the mirage i
think i'll be there too
the touch me tour is on sale now right
now
additional shows in clearwater florida
capitol theater september 11th
boston massachusetts the wilbur october
2nd
there's richfield connecticut at the
ridgefield playhouse october
9th atlanta georgia center stage theater
november 5th
royal oaks michigan at royal oak music
hall november 18th
minneapolis minnesota the pantages
november 20th
fun chicago illinois the vic theater
december 11th
also whitney's in a big film how it ends
is being released on streaming and in
some theaters
july 20th that's next touristy um
check it out this episode is the perfect
this is the perfect segue from women
that called crazy more than they should
to the podcast episode with nikki glazer
this is our first three-time guest i
believe
tim dillon ah this is our first female
three-time
guest no tim dillon
this is our second three-time guest uh
math is not my strong suit but we love
nikki glazer so much
she is back we get into it this is
what i like to call a tricky sticky
and hilarious interview also in a
conservatorship we go
both of us probably should be could we
get a deal jamie can you represent us
so nikki and i we talk we talk about
some pretty wild
stuff it's a very um deep dark and goofy
deep
dark and goofy conversation as as
our chemistry always lends itself to i
love you guys don't ride elephants enjoy
nikki glazer
maybe the universe is telling me you
don't need the computer maybe that's
just connect this is not
yeah this is not why would we want to go
to anywhere it would be fun to look up
some stuff no we're going to okay
i have to because i was like oh my gosh
we've never done that i'm obsessed with
uh celebrity net worth the website i
feel like they're always wrong
right i'm upset well maybe but some
someone like daisy fuentes how much
how much play in that game how much i'm
gonna say
god daisy fuentes i would say 16 mil
based on like hearing her name a lot in
the late 90s early 2000s yeah because
everyone in the 90s is financially super
smart and she invested in some kind of
like
and i trust daisy with her money i think
she's played it smart
like i think that's why she that's she
chose to step away
because she was like i made enough money
and i wanted to get out uh-huh that's
why we haven't heard her name in a while
did
honestly where the hell is daisy fuentes
oh i know all about where
how much is she worth am i even close
i'm waiting for my computer to
boot up what do you think i i well i've
googled this many times
what did you think i am being i was like
oh she was an mtv vj i know what mtv
pays
not a lot but back then maybe it was a
bigger deal and da-da-da and then like
a lot of people that were on tv in the
90s if they didn't get a vitamin get in
on a vitamin
saying she got in on some kind of ab
machine or a uh like a
a box set of dancing things that's
so obsessed like eric knees yes yes
like there's some kind of uh yeah 90s
aerobic crazy
yep she i'm obsessed with like the side
hustles because we pretend right now
that like actresses didn't always have
side hustles like whether paltrow having
goop like reese witherspoon having
draper james
jessica alba having honest we're like
while the sudden are like actresses have
to be like own companies this always
always
suzanne summers is one of the richest
people on the planet she was on a sitcom
for she wasn't even the original fucking
yes she was she was the original
christie on three's company
okay she started this huge empire of
like staying young
and the thigh master and she's got
billions of dollars um daisy fuentes
did get on an exercise uh thing
with her own line of exercise clothes at
kmart
yes that's uh okay kohl's yes that
totally people think kathy ireland she
was this famous model that's it no
there's a lot of money in k-mart goals
and by the way yeah
kathy ireland has all her money from her
line of furniture most people
might not even know about kmart
wow she didn't know that she didn't
build them yeah they said can we give
you a bunch of money to put your name
your name is and you like sit on a couch
so
and we you never really hear about
that's crazy adam levine
had a line of clothing for women for
women at kmart
and it was so it's just to me that is
such a lie
i just remember thinking like this is
such bullshit i hate when the celebrity
actually doesn't use the thing like i
believe jennifer hansen uses smart water
that's why i like drink smart order i'm
like
i bet she actually uses that so no adam
levine but
like because these girls are supposed to
buy these clothing because like adam
levine might like
like me if i wear kmart he would spit on
you maybe like like i don't think would
never talk to someone who shops at kmart
is the most dishonest thing i've ever
heard it's just wild to me
i want to trust people you have a vein
coming out in your foreheads
angry i've never seen you this obsession
i mean i could really do it the whole
time i see myself sometimes and i go
you're just
imitating her face sometimes to look
pretty it's it's to do it all the time
it's very charming though
because she is so good at being
flustered or frustrated and so fucking
charming about it that's why she gets to
be her
yeah why don't we do that more yeah i
like i've been watching the morning show
and studying her like faces that's
you know she she's aging in a way that
i'm like oh she's now matching my age
but she's like 20 years ahead but it's
like
she's starting to look like me suddenly
like it's like oh okay
and so now my my forehead can do the
same things and i see the wrinkles i
keep them now and i'm fine with it but
i like in terms of endorsements i'm not
going to endorse something
and if i do i'm not going to like say i
use it i don't lie
i'm not going to lie for any amount of
money i don't think
and or i will literally if an alcohol
company offers me enough money i might
start drinking again just to keep it
honest and get the money
but like i won't be like i love this
product and then not use it
i love white cloth so much i relapsed
yes how good of a product it is
i started getting duis again and it was
worth it i just want people to be more
honest and i get so sad especially like
celebrities that i trust i do this i say
i'm like i use grapeseed oil from whole
foods as my main
oil before bed but i also am on fucking
peptides i also get to go get like
like the fucking thing where they fry
your face i'll be honest
i do all ferrous over you're honest i
know but it's like if
if you just saw me doing a a campaign
with like oil of a layer or whatever
you should have i mean why
no there have to be makeup companies and
beauty companies that the problem
stuff is a lot of it's tested on animals
there you go well there's your honesty
you would not do uh
let me but let me ask you if you were
didn't have money and there was a big
opportunity to
promote something that it's a tricky
situation because then you go
you can do more good with your money
because there's that's it so it's also
okay there have been a couple
campaigns that i came close to doing
that are cruelty free but then you find
out oh no because in china you cannot be
cruelty free even if you're cruelty free
here they still make you like still make
poke rabbit in the eye
even if it's like we could just make
this out of a piece of aloe they're like
no you have to stab
a rabbit i've said because we're this is
the way we do it i literally said i was
gonna do a i really wanted to do a
documentary where i said
all the companies that are testing on
animals do it on me instead like i'll do
it
like you can do it on me put it in my
eyes like i because there's there's no
real need to do it because then we have
to launch a like
it's whitney cruelty free line i'm gonna
be worried that
only emotionally cruel they just lock
you in a cage like in those little red
beady eyes of like
you in a cage like like you've seen the
testing thing
anytime it comes up i'm like get out of
here peanut i know you don't communicate
shivering shaking scared is my kink
so i'm getting way more out of it yeah
just
poking me with sharp things in a cage
it's like my dream that's actually my
that's where mine is
yeah i wasn't sacrificing myself for the
good of animals oh i'm sorry it was just
a specific kingdom
sexual fantasy that i've been working
with um but uh but yeah so a lot of
these places that are cruelty free here
in order for them to be sold in china
which is where
all the money gets made right it has to
be so then you're like a fuck
but yes if a brand that is uh
not cruelty free is gonna give a bunch
of money and i pass on it
someone else is gonna say yes and
they're probably not
i could say yes and then donate all of
it to beagle freedom project which
fights
cruelty you know what i'm saying yeah i
mean uh yes i do know what you're saying
and i think you should
because a lot of people there's a lot of
like things where it's like i'm just
learning about like investing my money
and stuff and like companies and then
i'll go like well this company is like
allied with this company and they donate
to this and they're like bad and like i
shouldn't invest in them it's like
no i should fucking because some asshole
is gonna invest and do something evil
with the money
i'm gonna fucking take the money and do
something good with that well that's
what i said
jokes that might trigger people to have
panic attacks about certain subjects
that you might in the audience of people
they might trigger
get triggered because you use the rape
or use you talk about a subject that
might
send them into a fucking spiral i get
really nervous about that sometimes
because i've seen it happen and i
i've seen a comic i saw a girl have a
panic attack and leave when i was in the
hallway waiting to go on
and like and and he got very defensive
of like i'm going to say what i want and
i'm like but that girl's night is
through it and we have to acknowledge
that
i did a joke about ray like i don't even
know that it was like a
i don't remember the joke but this
person's a good enough comedian that he
handles those subjects in a way that i
mean i it doesn't
for me it didn't matter what the joke
was as much as that could happen even if
you're as delicate
as you can with a joke and it's like
that's not a joke making fun of rape
victims that's a joke about the subject
you can even just mention the subject of
rape which is not a joke that
could actually get you in trouble in
terms of like you were
punching down at rape victims the word
rape could trigger someone you know just
mentioning it
uh cut to i could say that comic raped
her
and that was the situation she was
watching her
joke about it and i'm like what are you
so upset about you
bought a shitty panic attack yet because
everyone else was excited
so i see this situation slightly
different no i agree with you i
i know i like was so upset for her and
like i was like fuck and i it made me
think about all the times
i may have said a word that makes
someone feel that way but i argue
that the things i talk look when i bring
up that word i don't do it lightly it's
because i'm i'm not trying to make a
rape joke so that i can make
that girl feel weird and like everyone
groans and like
i'm edgy it's because i have things to
say about
rape culture because i want i want to
talk about rape because
and sexual abuse of any kind i'm doing
this whole thing about molestation right
now and
i i it's very uncomfortable because i'm
still navigating it but it's
has so much information that people
don't have about child abuse
child sex abuse and because i've done
the research because for some reason i'm
kind of like
fascinated by it because it's something
that is in the shadows obviously but
it's in the shadows because
that's the way molesters want it to be
they want to live in a society where you
can't talk about molestation on stage
because if you do
a victim goes oh you shouldn't say the
rape word you shouldn't say talk about
your molestation
okay there's more shame around it equals
when i molest someone they won't tell as
many people because
you can't say it on stage you can't make
jokes about it so i think talking about
these things i
reason it i'm putting information out
there with my jokes
joking about this is not condoning it
and it is not
no perpetuating it no child molester
that never molested a kid
saw you do a joke and go oh my god now i
want to go i'm going to pull the trigger
now that she did that joke
like yep to say that a comedian's joke
about
rape about molestation about
or or that a woman on the cover of vogue
magazine
is why young girls are anorexic that is
minimizing the disease and the act
because you're saying a fucking comedian
that everyone knows as a comedian as a
silly goose and says silly things
has the power to make someone molest a
kid or rape someone
you're you're taking the accountability
off the person yeah
no but you're also uh minimizing the
person's
yeah that it's up to me to to make no
sense you're not the person
monsters were monsters before they came
in here and they will behave
whether you stand or not but but one
more thing about what you're saying is
exactly right just to like back you up
on
this in terms of the the molestation
thing and pedophile so pedophiles
so alcohol so the engine of all
addictive abusive behaviors is going to
be shame or some kind of trauma so most
lying not being honest exactly or being
a psychopath sociopath that but yeah the
li
you lie because you feel shame about the
truth so it's all like a shame engine
right we're only as sick as
the secrets we keep so when um most
people that molest
were molested that's a fucked up thing
to process
and that doesn't excuse their behavior
but like understanding that this is a
i always think about that i don't think
anyone i have
this is a this is i want to address one
thing
i didn't even consider that my joke
might be like making it so that
molesters feel more comfortable mustn't
i might make more molesters
my fear with that joke and why i would
worry about getting canceled is that
i'm making victims who have already been
victimized by those things re-triggered
which
i will do something i can't it's a
minefield and you know what i
really will individually apologize to
those people whose night was ruined
because they went to go see a nicki
glazer show and they didn't expect to
hear about the word multistage their
life was already ruined by some of them
i get it but i will apologize to them
for putting them in a situation if if
some girl's crying and dry heaving in
the bathroom i will absolutely go talk
to her and say
and and listen to her and like
understand it from her perspective
but i still and maybe i'll shift my
reasoning of like this is doing more
harm than good i haven't found a way to
synthesize this data i have to make it
funny and palatable or
the people that have that reaction which
is we'll
get to in a second because i have people
that come up to me and they go
you made me laugh about for the first
time ever yeah
i laughed about my rape i laughed about
myself i was able to like
see that like you can go through
something like that and eventually one
day laugh about it like thank you for
showing me that's possible
thank you for showing me that just
because showing me that i'm not alone
just didn't happen to someone else
just because because by the way everyone
in the audience is going to have some
kind of
someone's side of cancer someone's been
hit by a car someone's an alcoholic
most people in if you're just a lot of
green most people
yeah i was i was very vigilant when i
was a kid against kidnappers
any met creepy men and i think it's
because
something i think i wouldn't if i was a
betting woman i would bet
on i got some things weird happened to
me when
someone wasn't watching with uh when i
was a baby and couldn't remember it
because
i had a fear of men and and i still do
being alone with men that
my mom's i always blame it on my mom's
sex talk to me which was like
if you're ever alone with a guy he'll
rape you like that was literally her
like don't be alone with men they'll
rape you that didn't i don't remember
that scaring me as much as just fearing
feeling fear of men before that and i
don't know if something
can we also involve ancestral trauma
because y'all i love you
because the fact that your mom said that
to you i'm not equal
something i go what happened to her what
happened or what was inherited because
like these fears are also inherited
and i'm sorry also women were getting
forced to marry older guys at like 13.
i mean on tlc i see it like it's happen
i watch it
it's like still happening so often but
it was the only way that your life was
before we were so fucking lucky to be in
a world where we can even
you know and by the way this is also
just america a lot of this is i don't
know how you're lucky right now of
course yeah it's amazing i am going to
because we have such an amazing
relationship that i'm obsessed with i'm
going to be able to say to you
can you just not bang the table because
i don't want it to you tell me that
every time and you can always tell me
that okay and i just
never i just don't want people to not
hear what you're fucking saying because
a lot of people on the show
if you like eat an almond and they freak
out so i just want to okay thank you and
i'll
you'll have to tell me again because i
will forget okay i'm so
except like connection with you uh and
so i'll forget like i'll be like oh god
you're
you know i'm obsessed with this i am too
well i and i'm
i'm a little bit like as i'm saying this
like can you say that you thought you
were molested
i read something what do you mean can
you say i think i was molested
because i don't remember anything brave
and like anyone listening is like
but maybe i'm just assuming something
happened because i was a baby because i
literally have been in sessions with my
therapist that i've had for a while and
i remember this is not a joke one time
she goes
hold on just one second she goes so
remind me when you were molested because
i know i have it and i go
i wasn't she was like are you sure
because this
is just and i'm like all the things all
of the checklists are there of like
my fear and then i start looking into
molestation and i realize
yeah but i don't mind sleeping naked
yeah the thing is i realize
that uh when i listen to this podcast
that i really recommend if you're
fascinated in the topic
good for you if you're fascinated
don't listen to anything else but if
somehow this
i'll play it on this podcast so that i
get to listen so yeah we'll play it here
don't worry
okay so it's a podcast called hunting
warhead that i got turned on to
from just a it's a you know one of those
like serial type uh
things investigative and it's about
child sex abuse images
aka child porn but that's a bad way to
say it because it makes it sexualized so
it's child sex abuse images oh great
great just so much
this is the one place where i say like
like it's interesting like where words
actually matter because like they do
i hate when people say comedienne it's
actually sex abuse
it's child sex diffuse victim i flubbed
that line
it's such a good joke and i've whenever
i fucking flub a good joke it's
sucked i was like it was like it was in
my head and i was trying to say present
while also like getting back too excited
about it
oh did you see it i can't wait to tell
you my story
i knew what you were doing joke i came
up with whitney
so i felt like a little doctor oh my god
like don't pop it don't love it you know
what it's like when you sound like a
great bird on text and there's something
spelling on it and then you have to do a
star and write like
streets i had a fucking banger joke
to rogan the other day i like sent it i
was like boom
and then it had auto corrected he was
like what are you doing are you stoned i
was like
ah you wrote dawg and then you correct
it and you write duck again you're like
no i mean duck and you're like
doctor why don't we just change fuck
to duck to duck why don't i don't duck
it now why don't we just say that
fuck you why don't we just embrace does
it feel as good as fuck
i know but the phone just is going to
decide how it
really is you should just acquiesce i um
so i'm sorry to get back
so i i imagine this podcast and it
really took me into this world
of child sex abuse images and the dark
web
and how these are made and what's
happening and how
how like and then there's this podcast
other podcasts that i recommend it was
sam harris's podcast making sense and
it's called uh the other pandemic and
it's a it's
that's the title of it it just came back
out last year and i avoided it because i
was like i don't want to know about
another strain of
fucking covid but it was about child
abuse
and it gave me all the details that i
need to five percent of the general
population
watches uh child sex abuse images aka
child pornography
five percent and let me explain that
five percent that's not five percent of
people aren't molesters that's not the
right percentage for that we know that
there's science behind that even though
people don't really come out we can't
document it but that's
that's not five percent of people are
molesters five percent of people are
though in the general population and
when you look in a room of people five
percent of those people are watching on
a regular basis
child pornography child sucks to be
sympathetic to dark web
on the dark web here is the thing those
aren't child molesters all of them
what's happening now with porn is
becoming it's so extreme there's so much
extremism online of like
decapitations okay i'm gonna watch a
girl in a cage now i'm to watch a girl
get spit on now i'm going to watch it
and then the most what's the most
extreme thing
children they're not even turned on by
children
being a molester you know around puberty
when if you are
attracted to children not it's that's
that's how you know yeah when you start
to change you're still a child kind of
and you can't there is a clear-cut like
definitive like that's when you know you
are a
uh better ass or a pedophile as i think
someone who is pederas i think pederast
is you haven't acted on it pedophile
pedophiles you're attracted to children
peter ass means you've acted on it
but but then pederast like they have to
identify themselves as that which means
they then implicate themselves and
everyone thinks they've done it and
they're lying
but also but also how yeah exactly so so
this is the
the the point about uh pedophile
rehabilitation or whatever if we're not
just going to send him to a fucking
and now my alligator there's a guy named
petter asked
p-e-t-t-e just google this
let's check in on her so how's she doing
i'm
so obsessed with this topic because and
i i feel like i can never say this
because it's just like you have to
really put nuance on it yeah so to me
the this q and on thing where it's like
queuing on people are fucking crazy
cueing on people
these are people that have heard whether
it's
you know it's it's it is not true but
there is a ton of child sex trafficking
in america
it's not out of like a pizza place it's
not out of a famous person's pizza place
in l.a no one in l.a eats carbs and you
know that there are no pizza places here
um with pizza much less fucking yeah
when you'll see like
a new like uh i don't know calzone place
or like a
like a bread company you're just like in
l.a that's a front that's what's going
on
that's really good yeah exactly when
they're like uh celebrities are eating
babies at a pizza place so i'm like
there's a peace place in l.a
oh yeah literally where it's like when i
found out there was a creepy
creep red bulls there that's definitely
some bullshit
no one's it was good there's fucking
pizza that's not cauliflower crust like
where is it i want to have a shame byron
when i heard there was a krispy kreme in
burbank they were like someone got shot
at a krispy kreme in burbank
i was like that was what you were like
square
that's so funny but i mean we have so
so let me hear about this really quickly
and why
it's so important that everybody
listening to this understand how
important this conversation is because
it's not just about i'm obsessed with
talking about it
because the effects like like the
effects of it are so big
that's it everything that's wrong with
the world is because someone was
molested and couldn't talk about it
that's it
okay so the uh q anon people the people
that are like
they're sex trafficking and they're
killing babies these are in my opinion
i'm generalizing
people that were sexually abused and
want to stop
it and they are like they hear that and
they just go into fucking fight or
flight protection mode they don't have
the
correct data and it is happening but not
there but not there
so it's like there is there this pro
this is a problem
you were molested obviously it's a
nightmare you don't have
20 years and 500 thousand dollars to sit
in psychotherapy and heal yourself
like you like what choice you have
you're just a victim and i mean when i
see
people like that like comment me on
instagram or have this like virtual i
look at these like twitter
things i'm like these are probably
molesters to me are all people that have
been
hurt hurt and are just dealing with so
much pain it's it's it's when you get
honked out in traffic when you get
yelled at you kill this or stop it if no
one will admit that it's a problem a lot
of it is is
within the family families are invested
in being in denial about it the sexual
abuse in my family
everyone knows about it but no one
discusses it it didn't happen
because then they'd have to feel the
guilt sorry yeah it was our fault that
it happened
it's not it was but listen it is but it
wasn't because
even if you because i always say i
wasn't melissa and my parents think
they're like proud of it and i'm like
but you shouldn't be because you put us
in a lot of places where we could have
been
and i became obsessed with molestation
when i was young when as soon as i found
out about kidnappers i had a younger
sister
and i made fucking short shitting
molested there would be times that my
parents would let her go and i'd go
no like there was a weird van like i was
obsessed with my sister getting molested
which also makes me feel like something
must have happened
it's a weird thing for a kid to worry
about if it has i mean because as a kid
you'll also like
jump off a tire swing and not think
my first word was dangerous i would go
dangerous my first multi
besides mom and dad my first word was
dangerous and i point out dangerous
things and can i ask you something else
that why this is so fucked up and
important as also it's like
you know i know so many women as moms
that already feel guilt that they
have to that work all day but they can
afford to have someone watch their kid
or daycare like the idea of like i have
to choose between watching my kid like a
hawk every five minutes
and fucking having a job
it's like it's such a fucking nightmare
don't blame the victim's parents
don't underestimate the power and the
conniving trump ted bundy
got women in his car over and over and
over again it works
stupid why didn't why didn't this girl's
friend
know have a pinner stomach about that
guy it's like what
my dad i got made me so mad recently
there was a girl a couple years
old there was a girl a couple years ago
i was doing this as a bit but
it's just it needs to be said there was
a girl a couple years ago that
drunkenly walked stumbled out of a bar
drunk totally drunk okay
i'm not saying that i love when people
tell stories of when they were like a
friend of mine was telling a story about
when she got roofed and she was
and i only had two drinks and i'm like
you don't need to say that to me you
could have had 18 drinks i'd still
believe you okay
because that doesn't need to be a part
of your story because that doesn't
fucking matter but i had had two drinks
yeah like
or she goes but it was only two and i'm
like i don't need to know that you can
have as many drinks as you want
if you know when you're fucking roofied
as opposed to when you've had a bunch of
cops
my skirt was below the knees so like
yeah what and exactly
we're still apologizing it happens
because we're it's a reflex now as we
know it's the first thing people say and
in every church
like even if we don't get out before
christmas and then you got roofie yeah
we even know that
we set up stories to go yeah well i
shouldn't have been doing it that so
my dad called me after this girl she got
into the wrong over she stumbled up
there's security footage i remember when
it came it was
tragic she gets in the wrong uber just
happens to get into a murderer's uber
the worst she won the worst lottery like
you get how many times have i gotten the
wrong uber
so many freaking times and it just
wasn't the guy that would murder a woman
you know i just got lucky
and my dad called me up and he goes you
i go dad he goes
that can you imagine like he's just
scared for me because he knows he takes
it i take uber so he's trying to like
put out information like she shouldn't
have been just getting in ubers like
that and i go i
i do that all the time but here's what
i'll say you do take them to your
home and they know where you're staying
they know where you know everything else
about it is
like yeah by the way yeah it's we're
giving a different person our home
address
every day like what are we so foolish to
get in the wrong one except
the right one wouldn't might maybe i
could have been emerging you know what i
used to do
i was like okay i can't get murdered by
an uber driver like i know like whatever
i'm high risk and
security people told me not to and
whatever and then they're like you
cannot let an uber
driver take you to your home because
then they know where you live you
fucking moron and they can sell that to
other people whatever and i was like oh
great great yeah okay so i'll just have
him drop me off at like a different
house you have to walk in the dark home
no by the way
your neighbors get murdered that's what
i said i didn't realize that like two
months later i was like if he comes and
murders me he's gonna think i live here
oh my god can you imagine if there was a
that would be so
fucking they like the idea of like i'm
so sorry you guys said he thought he was
murdering me and he murdered you
and like oh my god whitney
endless guilt i had a guy come to my
house and i would always pretend
that i i would take pictures without my
house in the background and like on my
street
and then four neighbors down we're like
here's a ring camera of a guy
like knocking on the door last night
looking for you um
i was like oh my god i'm so sorry yeah
it happened to you that exact thing
happened holy shit yeah
it's this is so the girl got in a car
with the murderer
oh sorry the girl got in the car with a
murderer he he murdered her so
she got the most she literally it's like
a fish jumping out of the water and
falling in a fisherman's boat right like
it's like the worst thing that happened
she just picked the wrong goddamn car to
get into
she got murdered okay so my dad calls me
he's like that would never happen to you
and i go yes it would
this is someone you know no no this was
a news story big news story this woman
you they
footage of her it was it was in jail i
don't know
how it ended yeah they caught i believe
they caught this guy immediately because
it was just
everything about the case was out the
next day on daily mail and i was looking
at all the footage everything's tracked
so they know
if you're a murderer and you're in an
uber no no she she got into
a regular car that was not an uber
she thought it wasn't her uber and she
got into the back of a guy's car and he
was just like
i i honestly had a joke about it where
he was probably like god i don't i want
to murder someone today and i just don't
want to
if i'm supposed to send me a sign and
she's like is it cool
and he's just like you know like that's
why i don't like god sending sign like
always looking for signs because it
could be the thing
that like she just got unlucky there
wasn't anything that girl did that i
wouldn't do and that's why i told my dad
i go
because he goes you would never do that
he wanted to convince himself that his
daughter is going to be smarter than her
but the truth is i'm not even though i
don't drink anymore i get into wrong
ubers all the time
and my dad was like you you look you
look to look at the license plate and i
go dad sometimes
i just know and then sometimes i like oh
like i didn't know
and and he goes well still if you got in
there that wouldn't happen to you
because i thought you did for it
because he always taught my dad always
taught me if i ever got into a car if a
guy ever tries to get you
into a car just try to do anything to
not go to the second location because
you're not going to go
do a podcast like he's taking you to the
woods to kill you yeah
like the second location is dead so even
if you have to
like steer the car on the highway and
flip it a bunch of times
you might there's a less chance you're
going to die there than that certainty
you're going to die and wherever it
takes you
to do whatever the other but here's the
other thing that's triggered about that
sorry just to be in there yeah no
granular about this because emily got an
uber recently and they
took her this to a crazy like backwoods
area with no cell reception like super
around
and like kept pulling over and stopping
like it was just like
yeah it was horrible i i got out of the
car and just like sobbed to stare
she was like she was like she like could
it was and it was it i know exactly
where they were it was a place that i
was like
i can see how this person would take
that route but it's five miles out of
the way
and it is a place that like never has
cell reception but you could have gotten
out of the car
i could have here you didn't know how
close to my i had no idea it was if
you're really being murdered and you
didn't want to make a scene if
it turns out you're not that happened to
me i was i didn't do an uber and it was
the wrong car but the right license
plate but different car color and
everything i got in
and there were two guys driving and i
just didn't even think about it i was
like late for this hair point
appointment i was in a weird town in
florida in the
jacksonville florida i get in and it's
two guys and i go are you allowed to
have two people and they just didn't
really talk to me they looked
like two guys that were not uber drivers
to me they were both wearing like wife
beaters like kind of junky car and i'm
like
oh my and then i look i'm not joking you
sawed off
uh door lock okay and i
what i did i texted andrew my opener and
i go this is my location i'm in the back
of an uber with two people i
we're driving in the direction i'm
supposed to be going but
this is not looking good and i go i i
honestly think i'm
i prepared myself to be raped i was like
this is it this is like
when you get raped you probably go oh
i'm about to be raped you might maybe
have that moment as a woman you haven't
had a thing of like just don't don't
make don't i was like
what do i do be as calm as possible to
reduce the amount of
danger right now like deer in the
headlights they freeze they
the reason deer freeze is not because
they're dumb and whatever they freeze
in case the threat's gonna keep on going
and not see them so we also do have this
freeze response
that's like when people like i should
have screamed i should have yelled it's
like no we are wired to just
freeze in case the threat passes you
know but then it's be as loud as fucking
possible you're so right the freezing
took place but i want to just say
even if the door had been open and we
would have been at a stop sign i
wouldn't have run out because of the
chance of how stupid that would look i
always can put myself in a position of
any of these times when it's like it was
my fault i got molested i got raped like
even if you maybe maybe you did
something that was like
that you go no but mine's different i
really did it like you don't know how
you're gonna act in these scenarios ever
again and you can
never ever tell someone why did you do
that my friend got held up at gunpoint
the other day
and uh on fairfax and carlisle's
boyfriend
got hung held up a gun point and like
these kids were they said they were like
you know
really young kids and they were he could
tell the kids were as scared yeah
and a lot of times that's why murders
happen because kids get so scared they
just they just do
they they're shaking a lot of
when women get murdered the murderer
is obviously a psychopath not not
defending their behavior they were just
not always a psychopath
or yes or a sociopath but a psychopath
famously
like in prison when they study their
brains a lot of when they kill someone
to them they're not
taking someone's life they're just
solving a problem because they don't
have empathy they're not like right you
know what i'm saying so yeah
like i had to do that to get the thing
that i wanted it's this that's all i
think about is what i want no i was just
gonna rape her but then she started
screaming and i had to stop the
screaming
yeah like i didn't i was i'm not a
murderer i just had to stop her from
screaming so loud
that's so so it's like that's what they
raise yeah they think of it like a
computer like i just shut down the
computer because it was having a
malfunction yeah i raped her and i was
gonna take her back and find the volume
so i just then she kept
screaming so i just killed her if she
just you know what i mean
that's sort of how they think so a lot
of times and when you know something
like that when you've like studied
murders a lot which we all
are doing now you go like okay if
they're going to rape me maybe i just
deal with that
because if i scream they'll kill me
because to solve the problem so i
shouldn't scream
right now i can't now i have to remember
to scream fire instead of rape like all
these
things there's all these rules but
there's always someone that you're gonna
go like
when i when he got held up at gunpoint
he did not do what the guy said he just
froze he didn't know what to do
and i remember her his girlfriend who
was so horrified was like why wouldn't
you get on the ground like you could
have been shot you didn't do with the
ego
i don't know there's no but by the way
there's no way
if you move that could be why exactly
yeah there's no you can do that all day
but we all do that like
i should have just done this one thing
that would have been it's like you don't
know how you're ever gonna act and you
can never judge someone for how they act
in an
emergency where they think they're about
to be murdered how you if you're going
to freeze if you're going to jump out of
the car
you hope that you hear enough these
stories that you can prepare yourself
when something happens but you don't
you're here you don't know you don't
know it also it's like i remember
when like watching the like derek
chauvin
you know execution for nine minutes and
my brain is like why didn't anyone
fucking run in there and stop it like
why is that bystander effect yeah and
you're like why
we're just filming there's a lot more
how did no one run in
but it's like because like i can say all
day that i would have
like you know but like who who knows
there's
no there's an amazing st uh uh i i
learned about this i have to remember
what the case is
of a woman it was in an apartment
complex and this was i i think i studied
this and it's like yeah this is a the
it's the bystander effect it's a kitty
genevieve's uh in 1937
i believe or maybe no this was in the
60s i think it was later yeah she was
she was coming home from work and she
got stabbed by a guy
raped and stabbed screamed for like 15
minutes they all heard
100 100 people like so many people heard
her no one called because everyone
assumed someone else called
someone else called and then the guy
came back and killed her and came back
and
finished her off as she begged for her
life when she could have been saved so
many times
and the thing is like you you and even
if you're someone like let's say that
like
you you um maybe you're someone who grew
up and you
your sister got molested and you were
the one that told on your stepdad for it
and you saved your sister and that's why
it stopped and then you hear about a
case where you go that brother
didn't tell on the step-dad uh i would
have
i i can say i would have because i did
no you can't say that you would have in
his case
you don't have the same life as that
child did just because you were in the
same circumstance
stop this i would have done that you do
not know if you were born into that
person's body and had their experience
and had their brain which is a different
brain circumstancing limiting
limiting uh you don't know what you
would ever do even if it's the same
scenario that you've been in you can't
empathy is not about putting on
someone's shoes because wearing your
body in someone else's shoes it's
literally being in their body with their
same experience you don't
know what also human human beings are
wired it depends on how your amygdala
works your ancestors trauma like many
things
but like you know most of the time if
you're in a dangerous situation
freezing is the uh most auspicious thing
to do for your safety
like in our brains our bodies also
jurassic park
our brain our bodies know more than our
brains for the most part so it's like
when a bear when you see those women
where a bear is like sniffing a person
and they're just standing completely
still and you're like
run you motherfucker but it's that
that's the worst thing you can do
because food runs you'll never ever
outrun a bear i know with i'm so scared
of bears i have dreams about bears all
the time bear doesn't think that you're
a prey until you run
until you run when you run just kiss
your lifeguard you have to just sit
there and fucking hopefully not be on
your period so you don't smell like
blood
and uh just let it fucking sniff you and
you will be safe it
seems so like um counterintuitive
counter-intuitive it's like the way that
moose
defeat bears this fascinates me because
this is like it changed my life in the
way that i
i moved through life because i used to
sort of be very um
not pugnacious but always at war like
defending myself and because i'm like
i'm protecting myself i'm gonna stand up
for myself so i'm like
this person like disrespect me i'm gonna
fucking go there is a person
that i know is um hurtful to other
people in my business
yes and uh i want to fucking go
it's all about the timing and it's all
about waiting and waiting and waiting
for someone to sort of ram you so the
way
hannibal burris so they do come out and
make like we all have to wait for that
sometime
or to have it happen to you so that you
have enough evidence that people trust
you because if it's all here say
i know about someone that i'm dying to
cancel i am getting uh
there's a girl who told me about a lot
of abuse happening on a show that she
worked on
and i already sensed it because i did
the show and i was like yeah i feel
it at just being someone who's being
protected from it and it's in the air
and here's what they do there it's like
it's like the people that actually work
there they can't do anything or they'll
lose your their job and have a bad
reputation forever as being like the
snatch it's like
it's it's like sometimes i go it's the
people that have no skin in the game
that actually should say something
because we wouldn't lose anything
yeah you know but it's also i'm the
least qualified to talk about it because
i wasn't there and now i just look like
a justice warrior like
like i'm the savior of everyone's
toxicity and then they're like well
whitney you made this roast joke 10
years ago and you're like
oh you knew you must have known or like
you you fucking
you made fun of these limpiness and
you're just like okay fair but
um yeah it's just the way oh yeah this
is
the literally they tweeted them
a metaphor that changed my fucking life
um yeah they released the bears nudes
um moose when a bear is charging them
they wait they do not run they do not
move at all
and at the last minute they put their
back leg out
and the bear breaks the bear breaks
their neck
on the moose's foot with the oh their
own force
oh my god wild so you can basically you
can see like there's videos online of
bears
charging a moose you're like why is that
moose fucking doing anything at the last
minute puts its back leg out
and then the bear breaks its neck with
its own oh my god own like vulnerability
jiu jitsu kill themself
on you yeah it's like that's i think
that's what like
all that stuff that all the rogan does
it's all about like
using things to like use their force
against themselves
it's like a whole it's like if someone's
coming through hold hold i know it's so
hard to do that
it's really hard because you want to
fucking fight back before it gets worse
but sometimes you have to let it get a
little bit worse so you have the maximum
amount of power and leverage
to protect yourself i tried to do a bit
about this i love that this is all in
like bits we're trying to do that are we
yeah because that's how we get out but
we're gonna figure it out
but as a comedian that's what we we are
able to go into these really dangerous
haunted houses and spaces
and like make it digestible to talk
about and think about
and then like it's a conversation right
so that's part of what we're heroes
we're heroes laughter is the best
medicine same thing i know
gotta do so after the best medicine we
are doctors we are
licensed yes we can doctor you can
either do
psilocybin or you can go to whitney's
early friday show
in ruining our own lives uh we help heal
yours
we do we really do i've been the bullet
i've been starting to take some of my
own advice that i give my like podcast
listeners because i've heard so much of
like
you've made me look at life this way and
this way and sometimes i go what would
nikki do like i literally go what was
the person
what would i want what advice would i
give to myself yeah because i talk to my
podcast listeners like they're my best
friends and i just want them all to have
such good days because it's kind of like
a morning show of like
just like let's be honest with ourselves
let's like kind of let things slide like
don't blame people that hurt you but
just know that they've been hurt try to
under have empathy
and sometimes when i'm frustrated i go
like what would i tell my if i was my
podcast listener what would i tell her
and then i'm able to get out of it and
it's like
been it's it actually has been
therapeutic i hate that it comes back
and let me say this
let me say this to however you get there
it doesn't fucking matter if it's if
it's cheaper than paying seven thousand
dollars for a therapist that doesn't
like but um i'm trying everything this
is something this is helping my
my female friendships as well is when
you see a
um a female friend go and we all do it
the smartest of us the most mature of us
the most well meaning of us we're in a
bad relationship a relationship that has
obviously been
and you get in the dopamine and the
oxytocin you just can't see clearly
and then when someone comes to me i was
like i'm going to say to you what i
think you would tell me if i was in your
situation and it does like
make people less defensive also when
you're like i'm only going to say this
because i think it's what you would say
to me if the rules were reversed
and i'm not going to judge what you do
with it i think you'd say
this and this and then to me yes i think
that's what you would say to me
like that that wasn't really what that
wasn't exactly but but you but it was i
don't know
it was just no you didn't and that's
what i really like loved about seeing
you today and like when i walked in
to your room in there and just i was
just like i need you like i was on the
way here like trying to draft this
text that was gonna possibly blow up my
life or something you know and you were
able to
really convince me like let's take a
beat and run through a lot of you have a
lot of tools for processing these things
that
are valuable to me and so like i've said
a lot of tax i regret oh my god i'm
glad we're friends and that like reminds
me like i
feel like with your female friendships
like
i we've talked about this before but i
was so scared i was telling someone
recently
our history and i was like i was so
intimidated by her
didn't wanted to stay out of her way
didn't even want her to see me because i
didn't want her to like
hate me or like think that or like i
didn't want to bother like
i knew you knew i was just scared of you
and
thought that you were a different person
and then you are and
truly the person that i were absolutely
different than when we first met in 2006
but like the person i get to see now out
of you is like
there's just so much love like i just
love female friendship so
much and i love how quickly they can
come in like i fell in love with you
when i did your podcast the first time
coming on here and now it's my third
time and like
i really i'm just so female friendships
are the fucking best and i it happens
very it's like love at first sight and i
love how quickly it can happen and i'm
gonna know you forever but i do also
think that part of like i'm so glad
we're getting close now because it's
only in the last five years that i
wasn't a fucking man like i'm glad you
didn't know me no i i
when i was like i i knew when to come in
yeah yeah i wasn't ready for you i
wasn't i was
coming because i would have done
anything you said but i'm so glad you
didn't summon me
i'm so glad that we got to become
friends when i'm more
cooked as a person because i would have
been like walking on eggshells around
you were to hurt your feelings
because there's nothing worse than a
female friendship
where they give you bad advice because
they're worried about hurting your
feelings but they'd rather give you bad
advice that's going to hurt you way more
so
i was you know i always laugh about like
when you i always say never ask like a
girlfriend that
has known you forever for advice about
relation for them to be able to say you
always do this
remember jake remember so and so they
can give you a history of
and show you a pattern but like fresh
eyes on something like
because i hear a lot of like he's just
not calling because i think he likes you
too much
like you're right you're trying to not
you're trying to
stop me from having this heartbreak i
see what you're trying to do but it's
being it's so much just give it to me
real
give it to me i'm the person that's like
you said some things to me in there that
i was just like
fuck it's just like not what i wanted to
hear
and i'm only able to accept that from
you because i'm 37 years old
like i would have i was also ready to
say it to you in a way
that wasn't just fucking what do you
even i was able to say like
yeah you didn't you didn't i didn't you
didn't make me feel bad about who i was
for being in the situation i
am in that i got to because i'm not
making good decisions and it makes me
feel bad and here's
well the first thing i always ask is do
you want support for what you're already
getting you said that or advice or
advice
i'm happy to do either i will do either
if you want to send this right now
i'll fucking help you send it and i also
say i might not take your advice and so
when you give it to me like
i know that i'm safe not taking your
advice and you will still be friends
yeah i'll do the opposite
you'll still be but then i first want to
like what the person's at because most
people when they're asking for advice
they're asking for
a thumbs up on what they're already
going to do yeah that's what i was
looking for and then when you ask that i
go
no i want that means do you want me to
lie to you or what's the truth
it's clear that you need another rock
bottom on it like you need a reminder
you need a refresher
i've done it with with family members
that i was like okay we have i haven't
been in your life for 10 years
you know what i just need to see them
again and see if anything's changed it
hasn't
needed that remind sometimes you need
that you need more proof it's like you
need more proof
so get it i like that's why i keep
smoking pot like i
i've quit so many things that have like
gotten to bottoms where i'm like okay
well this is it
let's just ruin this thing that's
important to me so i'm gonna drop
drinking
i'm gonna stop having sex with men
before i'm in a relationship love it i'm
gonna stop having any starving myself
or binging i'm going to stop like oh i
i'm absent or
sober from all these behaviors but when
it comes to pot that's where we've
that's where i'm still struggling it's
like here's what i'll say that's a
fucked up one because maybe it will be
different this time with pot
it's always different this time it's
different sometimes it's killer
every strain of weed is actually
different
it's so true or like i'm like no this
time it might be different because in
fucking edibles they
cook weird so i don't do edibles anymore
i don't i'm off because
rogan is broken enlightened 70 days off
70 days off oh my god
i can still smoke weed and vape but
edibles like my brain i've talked about
in the podcast
it's a different drug you know that
right your body literally processes
edibles diff joe told me this it blew my
mind because i never was having good
edible experiences
it's a different drug than when you
smoke tea it's a completely
different thing in your body so there's
a reason why you don't like them
it's not pot but i'm also because of my
workaholism and need to always be like
productive at all times i don't want
something to kick in later
the 40-minute wait so i don't have that
kind of time well i can't manage that
that's kind of like but also 40 minutes
to someone else it's different 40
minutes to me is different
a minute feels like 40 minutes already
to me so i'm like it's been 40 minutes
it hasn't kicked in
i got a dud i'm going to take two more
yep these aren't working obviously this
oh i want a immediate
it's today we want the laughs right away
i don't want enough time
yeah i want to be high now i want
exactly i want it now i'm compulsive
that's what saw me fall and hit my head
on that fucking wall because i had
10 of those blueberries no yeah i'm so
glad you're not doing this
this is when i stopped i actually didn't
stop it wasn't that wasn't the fall the
ball that was in the rock bottom no no
that was like did you get that were you
filming
i did that was kind of a lucille ball
that was hilarious you didn't get a tick
tock out of that i was making content
we now take an abrupt break in our
i took an abrupt break that's called
that's
going to feel however we now take an
abrupt break
from the podcast that i have now uh
started calling two broken girls
uh my chat with nikki glazer and i
takes a a quick break so that you guys
can find out if there's something
interfering with your happiness or
preventing you from achieving your goals
especially since you're currently
listening to two women who have not
you guys over there you made a
great video okay they wrote that uh you
guys
no you made a video you put in great
last time emily put in green that better
help
uh i did the video the video you guys
made about better help last week
was okay your lines are over you're
welcome we know you loved our video
sound aside like most creative duos we
had some differences
and we broke up don't do your line
readers if you're mad
too what are you doing i do think that
in theaters and in plays and in movies
actors do you think that in theaters and
plays in movies that they shit on their
co-stars like this
are you leah michelle keep going i hope
so
i hope i'd literally michelle
accommodate anymore
when i was 32 against my will
we can so
benjen and i wrote a script and i just
don't think it can be made how about
amazing better help is at matching you
with your own personal licensed
professional therapist
i think it did oh you don't even haven't
heard it
i wrote a script and i we're gonna let
me just share the script okay let's
share
okay we're gonna read it for you now
because you can really
okay y'all are about to do a scene okay
wait we're doing a scene that is going
to explain perfectly
how better help can help okay and we're
going to do this like a real
production sound speeding
and action hey thanks for answering i
know you're at work
oh no worries i was just about to head
in and do a nose job on some famous
instagram baby
are you a dentist well yeah i started
off as a dentist but i took a few master
classes and now i'm exploring my craft
oh my god okay well that red flag aside
i'm about to get your opinion on
something
since i started my company i've been
really anxious i'm constantly stressed
and i just can't seem to shake the
feeling that it's all going to fall
apart and i'm some kind of imposter
oh i can totally see how you opening up
your own seafood restaurant on etsy
could be rough
but this has been your dream since we
were little kids remember when you used
to catch crawfish in the creek you
dropped them off
in my locker and those tiny envelopes
you if anyone can do this you can do it
it's just so much more pressure now the
thought of failure has taken all the joy
out of shipping shrimp
i just don't know if this is a good idea
anymore i need an honest opinion will
this company fail
i need to know if these feelings are
something i should pay attention to
emily
if there's anyone who's going to push
the limits of shellfish shipment
in the etsy appropriate packaging of
newspapers and old amazon packages it's
you
and if you don't believe me maybe you
should just call a licensed professional
it better help
see i think that was really good i agree
it had a story arc
it had a problem it was and we've never
entered the realm of seafood shipping on
nancy
at i mean i lolled and i've
you know i've been dead for 20 years
better help is not a crisis line it's
not self-help it's professional
counseling done securely online
this podcast is
[Laughter]
this podcast is sponsored by better help
not that any of us need it you start
every line like your maggie dame smith
this podcast is brought to you by battle
but
what are you doing whatever
you know i don't know who you love
people are
this podcast is sponsored by better help
and good for you listeners get ten
percent of their first month at
betterhelp.com
whitney support emily's shrimp business
we are good for you we do nothing if not
take serious care of ourselves emily
didn't you recently go to the spa
like during a work day yes and i learned
my lesson
ah self-care day oh look at these little
bows oh my god can you hear me oh yeah
we're in a meditative state you're ready
to relax
oh i'm just here to start a healthier
life with better rituals
perfect let's get you wet ooh ow this is
cold
well is this that's ew what is that oh
this is a plant goo
people love it is it traceable i got it
in my backyard oh gross oh that's hot
at this with my pocket ew this hurts why
oh this is a nice little roller very
soothing oh i don't like this it's not
very pleasant ooh
what are those lemons these are lemons
ew have an apple oh i don't
know your negative energy oh god gross
ooh
that was a butterscotch ooh that's
definitely not that's for breeze oh
gross
are you letting me on fire okay
blueberries i'm not enjoying this
oh you wanted something easy and
enjoyable well you should have tried
ritual protein powder okay
oh a ritual protein shake clean
plant-based formula delicious flavor
20 grams of pea protein no added sugar
and it's soy and gluten free
aren't they delicious oh are you still
here oh yeah
yum yeah i mean
i have so many questions about that
video because i am
incredibly impressed so why not shake up
your ritual
to make something new less scary ritual
offers a money-back guarantee if you're
not a hundred percent
in love plus my listeners get
ten percent off during your first three
months just visit ritual.com
essential protein today that's
ritual.com
whitney i just thought i'd do a soothing
voice before me and nicki start
squawking again
this is when i stopped because i i mean
i'm in everyone knows i'm in 12-step
programs and like a lot of addiction in
my family like have studied addiction
very deeply
is that it wasn't when i was taking too
much it was when
i started to hide it from other people
to not just when i stopped sharing
that's it so if i'm going you have a
blueberry you have a let's all have a
blueberry it's when i'm when you're
taking them around people
people know when you're starting when
people vape i found out one of my good
friends
when i put the blueberries in a shoe so
no one else would find them that's what
i was like
we're done here we're done because i'm
being secretive about it exactly and
that is why i only
smoke marijuana and i've been vaping
recently but i make sure i vape only
around people and like i'm not sneaking
it because when you start sneaking it
even if you're just trying to be polite
and you're not
it's not about shame there's it's their
shame because you're trying to
being polite well this isn't this annoys
other people
so what i i vaping weed i was doing it
all the time because you could do it
everywhere it doesn't smell it doesn't
linger and it kind of like dissipates
quickly so well you
everyone's brain is different some
people can never some people can only
eat edibles and never pick up a vape
every whole different thing you have to
know yourself a vape i feel like i can
have this puff of wheat in like
40 minutes later i'm like no
metabolizes quickly we pot smoke though
i've made a rule i go i'm only gonna
smoke
i'm literally for me to get high i have
to be around
if i want to get high with you guys i
can't just go in the bathroom real quick
i have to light i either have to roll a
joint which that to take so much time
might as well eat an edible like that's
40 minutes to roll a fucking joint
that's like i can't it takes too long
either someone gives me a joint all
right
i smoke out of a fucking pipe i have to
look like a crack addict and see myself
i
should pull up a mirror when i do it but
i literally i have to be accountable and
i can't do
if i do it on my own like sometimes my
roommate isn't home that's why i got a
roommate is i want to be accountable
about my eating
i want to be accountable about my
cleanliness and like
just being like she's like i'm your
super companion i thought
you were your friend i mean truly it's
not
like hey um so here's a journal i need
you to it's my podcast andrew i
make aware of uh orangevest on flights
and uh
he sits he doesn't sit next to me he's
in coach but that also makes me feel
more emotionally supported having him be
full of vitamins when i was dealing with
my eating disorder that's all like i
knew it was bad i knew
i needed help and that i wasn't it was i
was managing it
i thought i know you needed help um
because covet hit
and it just became glaring and i was
living in my parents house and sleeping
in my childhood bed that i lived in
when i you know i moved out to l.a when
i was 21 uh had a little success but i
moved back home when i was 25
to live with my parents and it was i was
drinking a lot then it was just
it was that was a bad time i eventually
moved to new york and never went back
until covid
went home just to wait out covered
because i was in between apartments
ended up staying there and by a couple
days in not doing comedy not running
around doing podcasts and everything in
like my lifestyle the eating disorder
was just like
it was all day waiting to eat because i
would just starve all day intermittent
fasting was a
gift to me as an anorexic excuse and
wanted to culturally
excuse to say to someone when you go to
a lunch a a few years ago i just ate i'm
vegan
i'm allergic to all the goddamn time so
you can starve and now finally you can
go i'm intermittent fasting everyone
goes good for you
you're like you're anorexic i am the
healthiest person on the planet
people go oh i've heard of that that's
not taboo instead of me saying which i
said in the end like when people would
see me like start my binge at the end of
the night at the comedy cellar i would
order like
1800 plates of food because that's what
it would begin it would go throughout
the night
i would have all this food and people be
like jesus christ and i go yeah i have
an eating disorder i would literally
like said i knew i had one i had
dabbled in going and getting some
recovery but what finally made me
look at it was the fact that kovad made
me see that
i i wish i had a loved one that wasn't
my i'm glad i have my family to live
with but i really wish i had a husband
or a partner to share this with and the
reason i don't is because i
am hiding an eating disorder and i can't
i would rather
eat in bed than have someone in my bed
and i would wake up every morning with
protein bar wrappers that i ate
throughout the night and it's just
that's just the norm that's the norm for
me in the morning to go
how many was it last night oh and then
the next day find some and i go oh were
those from the other days should i
did i eat nine last night like i'm
talking entire boxes of protein bars in
bed this is why i'm asking
you about how did you know like where
you're able to identify me because a lot
of times when other people tell you you
have an eating problem or other people
that's not going to do it no it actually
you go
thank you it makes you it validates you
love hearing a lot of times when people
are like you look really skinny you're
about a problem you're like nailing it
on one track
well that's why because i have it has to
be self-identified it has to oh yeah
for any addiction really you have to
like get to a point it helps that people
are honest with you
self-diagnosed diseases but when when
people do get ner like when people
i have a lot of women going like i've
had it before where
i'm i'm not doing anything tricky with
food or i was
which i shouldn't have felt guilty about
either like there's some kind of like if
you have anorexia there's some kind of
like thing that other women have for you
like a disdain a resentment of like
you're too skinny it's like i'm not
doing this because i want
to be hot i can't eat and i don't know
why
yeah it just is the only thing that
makes me feel okay
and i don't get it and i didn't it's the
only thing you can control i mean i did
beg for it in high school and i was like
i wish i could be anorexic and i like
threw a penny in a fucking well and it
became true you're a winner
no you're a winner if you want something
you'll get it when catching anorexia and
i really say
catch because i caught it like a fucking
illness i just it
so my anorexia went from being a
teenager not knowing how many calories i
need just being like i'll just never eat
again
almost dying hospitalized ended up
getting educated enough to manage it
where i don't pass out on stage like i
used to
i don't um you know almost get faint
when i'm
talking like i managed it right like no
one i could have gone on forever
not ever but it would have eventually
ruined my life in other ways but not in
a way that anyone would have seen
right and um and there were times i was
too skinny but it was too skinny in a
way that was like
applauded and like oh you're sample size
and like you're
you look like a supermodel like
something like that didn't close right
off when somebody says you look like a
supermodel it's
you're a little bit tall and you look
like a skeleton that and you look like
you're starving yourself because your
legs don't touch
and you have flag up i have wide hips so
i do have a thigh guy but it's not
because i
so sometimes i hate when girls are like
thighs are natural i'm like i
right now i'm not doing any fuck
anything with my food to try to be a
certain way my body
is what it is and i have to accept that
and right now it's good because
i got help because what i did was i was
desperate
it was uh march 2020 i was living at
home with my parents
everything was so scary nothing to like
call my nerves anymore my eating
disorder was surging i wanted a husband
and i was like
this is the time to do this so i got
help and i went on a cooking show
yesterday and i talked about i go guys
i would have turned this show down a
year ago i would have made up a lie to
get out of it because i
don't it's a show where they recreate
fast food and make it for you
and i don't eat fast food because when i
was anorexic that was just something i
said goodbye to even though i grew up
and loved it
or i i eat it now like i will let myself
but i don't eat because i just don't
crave it
if i wanted it i wouldn't want it
because i literally eat anything i want
now and that's wild to say
but if i want it i will eat it and allow
myself to have it because i trust myself
i have
up so yesterday i went on this fast food
show and it's like a funny comedy show
and i go they're like why are you here
and i go i wouldn't have been here a
year ago i have to say i'm uh
recovered from i'm in recovery for an
eating disorder and i can only now allow
myself to have fast food because i
it was the devil to me it was like
poison you could have never got me to
eat a chicken nugget i mean i'm vegan
so they have vegan ones but like eating
something fried i just would never eat
it i'm like i'm so grateful that i get
to be here now and do this and
i'm not going to starve myself today or
tomorrow because i ate more fried food
today
it's just all going to balance out and i
trust that i'm going to eat the right
amount
and so what i did when i got into
recovery was just become accountable for
it and start taking pictures of my food
and sending it to someone who would not
judge me for it and just thumbs up it
and uh i'll tell you i thought i was
eating eight protein bars a night
and then you start to see and then you
see the text and the pictures that
you're sending and i was like
it's way more than that and it's way
weirder there's a lot and then i started
to have it
because you can set denial and you can
you can you can think that you see your
problem
you can normalize the i used to drive
three times a dozen yogurt
to a frozen yogurt place on olympic i
would do three times a day to winning
i'm such a whitney
dude how did we know you told me about
the original frozen yogurt the big chill
you taught me about that yeah
because they had the zero calories stuff
that made you be in fetal position
because you would cramp up somebody have
diarrhea i would be
crying every night i would always tell
my boyfriend i was like i'm tftf too
too full to fuck every night i that's i
wasn't having sex that was too
full from eating of like chemically
frozen froyos with sprinkles that i
would drive to two different locations
because i didn't want them to see me get
yeah that's what that's what i would do
and i'd go you would lie and be like oh
i'm getting a bunch for like i have
friends staying with me so i'm gonna get
a bunch of frozen oh
so that i could like you go into those
places and i'm like set up some chairs
and let's start an eating disorder
meeting right now
by the way all the people that work
there they know i call these air foods
anorexic foods are like popcorn things
that are just you can binge on that
don't fill you up by the way this is
when i was doing something called fit
modeling where just to pay for college
where you like stand and they sew
clothes on you
we would dip cotton balls in orange
juice and eat cotton balls with orange
juice
or like sugar-free or just as a no i
think
it was real no because we added some
water sugar yeah this is sushi wouldn't
faint yeah and then everyone would eat
broccoli with no
um raw broccoli and then this girl that
i fit model with came down
from baltimore and she slept in my she
was like a really good friend of mine we
slept in bed together
and both of us at like 2 a.m woke up
and for like an hour we're trying to see
if the other because we were both sleep
eaters we'd wake up and like fucking
tear 90 protein
so we were both and then it was like uh
she was like are you up and i was like
yeah she's like what are you doing and i
was like nothing i was just gonna like
go get a water and she's like oh yeah i
love to have water and we both like
sleep ate binge together we had to go
down to the 7-eleven under my building
to buy more and it was like i had a
partner in crime too
so it was so great to get one because
it's such a it's such an isolating
disease
oh i'm not crazy someone else do this
and then i was like
off to the fucking races as soon as
someone else is i found someone as sick
as me
oh my gosh you're the same thing i was
like we're just coping
it's like i didn't realize how toxic it
was to find someone that could relate
that could be
you could shoot up with what i needed
was i'm gonna go this is
wild and no one that's why i was
screaming
it beforehand i was so in need of help i
was talking about it all that i was very
honest
i thought i was being honest about what
i was doing with food and like being
like i want to change it i don't know
what to do
but when i first when i started to
document it and send it to someone that
just wouldn't judge it she just thumbs
up it like cool
eat that like it would be like i would
seriously have like eight protein bars
as i'm laying in bed on my lap
with like the you know those smart
sweets that are like 90 calories and two
grams of sugar yes yes i would eat like
four bags of those gummy worms like yes
and the constant like amazon packages
being mailed to the club that i'm
performing and so that when i get there
i have my certain protein bar otherwise
what am i gonna eat
yeah it's just exhausting but yeah i
just started seeing this and i'm like
i'm 36 living at home with my parents
and like
what is going on like i have to do
something and then i just took a chance
that maybe this lie i've been telling
myself my whole life of
i can't eat three meals a day i can't
eat normally
because i'm different i will get obese i
will get fat if i eat normally
but i said this i had this i had a
narrative too because you can never eat
fat right oh yeah by the way we're also
fucking lied to and like marketed to and
whatever i was like if i eat fat i'll
get that
so i would only eat like sugar-free
snack wells that have
so much which is a billion sure i'm
getting and i realized sugar's the
problem
i just had a fucking avocado on a piece
of toast
i'd actually my hair would grow still
have problems with that
like i still have aversion to things
like fast food like fried things it's
just like i
so they were so poisonous it's suddenly
like all of a sudden this world opened
up where i'm like
oh you can drink there's so nice to me
because like you know the idea that we
can't
we're not supposed to eat at chick-fil-a
because of their homophobic vested
interest that's the idea of like
i'm like not because i'm like an
advocate or an ally i'm just i don't i
don't need to do something yeah i'm not
getting married until gay people kink me
up married not because no man loves
me and wants to marry me and that most
of the men i
date are gay let me turn my failure into
being a hero
yes yes refuse to get married until yeah
veganism that's
a easy way to be restrictive and so i
always feel guilt about veganism because
i get worried people are like
she's using that to be anorexic but i
don't need to worry about that anymore
because i was using it before even
though it was
well-intentioned i was using it it did
support my anorexia even though it was
well intentioned
things uh when people criticize me about
something the only time it hurts me is
when there's a little bit of fucking
treatment
there's not truth to it anymore i am
vegan for the reasons i'm vegan and
i it doesn't mean that i don't restrict
or don't feel guilt when i
overdo we can say that we can say you
can like in recovery like
alcohol is not you never say like i'm
fixed or i'm not an alcoholic anymore
you say i'm in recovery you say
and with um from what i understand in
eating disorder uh programs is not i
don't have an eating descending
disorder anymore i just have disordered
eating and that's something that's gonna
not be
fixed or healed it's only maintained yes
i believe that i maintain so it's like i
can have disordered eating and that
doesn't mean i'm not ostensibly eating
health but i am thinking
i can't believe i'm fucking eating this
it's still taking up space in my brain
and i still
now when it comes and i go that's so
funny because it's all based off of like
lies you've been told like there's no
science that supports what you're scared
of it's gonna happen right now
you can't get obese tomorrow and even if
you are you're going to be the same
person and but that's
that will be another thing but if you
like i mean because i do know people
that like
have to lock foods in drawers absolutely
and someone else opens the thing because
it's a trigger food and
they know that there are it's it is like
there's a chemical dependency and then
there's a psychological
coping in yourself soothing and the idea
is you have to figure out what you're
soothing
that's the tricky thing and then you
gotta heal the wound that makes you want
to self-soothe because actually
disordered eating any kind of a
restaurant about food only eating
something purple whatever
that was the first um anesthetic that
kids uh children have access to before
they have access to drugs before they
have access to alcohol before they have
access
food is something you can self-soothe
with as a child so it's like it's the
wound
it's the oldest wound it's one of the
and it's the cheapest
most legal drug that isn't regulated and
you have to eat three times a day so
imagine saying hey cocaine
addict that keeps like doing competitive
driving you have to do cocaine
three times a day like don't you can't
overdo it and like you just said about
like i'm not gonna get
uh obese tomorrow if i eat today but
like you know crack addicts can't go
like if i do crack right now i'm not
gonna die tomorrow
but you eventually will yes that's why
we don't do it today because then we'll
do it tomorrow and the next day and the
next day and the next day and then we'll
build a case that like
the way i'm doing it now actually i
think it's different this time but the
fears around
like i used to just think like if you
eat a french fry like it's just
and that for some people french fry can
lead to something that will
ruin their life for me i had to figure
out when i started talking to people
with
eating disorders and different ones and
how they're recovered i learned there's
just everyone's different it is it's
much more tricky than just getting sober
because you still have to eat like just
like you're saying so
for me mine was like okay let me just
experiment i could always go back let me
try to eat
three meals a day that are like real
meals and not like a little bit smaller
than what someone
i always want the least calories on the
menu i'm dining with people i always
want to get the one that has the less
amount of calories and then but also
busy people who the even like i'm ready
to eat healthy and balanced like who the
fuck has
time unless you subscribe to daily
harvest
who the fuck has time to truly free
healthy meals together
today it's a full-time job well i
started like planning them out so i
started go so i went in a way of like
and and guess what whitney those meals
yes i was doing three meals a day which
i was like okay that's my rule for
myself as long as i do that i'm absent
from an eating disorder then how do you
define a meal
so i met with a nutritionist but boy did
i start doing little tricks where i
would get
the sugar-free almond butter or the what
you know instead of what i really like
wanted
make sure cake is also sugar-free is
like sure now yes
sugar is not great is it whether they're
sick or not
so let me know it's tricky okay well i
would get
uh you know the 35 calorie rice cakes
instead of the 40.
i know exactly what you guys are doing i
know i know which ones you're talking
about so and i still do and you know
what because i like them by the way
they're i don't like the apple cinnamon
ones i like the plain and they are 35
calories
it's like ones that are 45 calories
actually they're 70
the ones you're talking about no i hate
those ones i'm talking about those
quaker oats lightly salted or
no salt 35 calories they're great they
absorb tofuty cream cheese in a great
way you put
peanut butter on top of that blueberries
delicious it's just a consistency i like
but i have guilt about like it's the
most
it's the i only know about it because i
picked the one with the least calories
but as i then i was starving i was then
i
then i was like kept eating into the i
was like it's not enough
i'm i'm i am different i i can't have
three meals a day i'm
still gonna binge at night but then i
looked and i go you're just not eating
enough drink you're still
starving yourself so then i literally
started waiting
to prove your narrative like five to six
hundred calories when i wake up which is
like
i wouldn't let myself have that for my
first dinner
would that would like that would be
breakfast 500 600 calories
i would have just i had to do that like
back in the day if i had to like a
important meeting and i have to eat
breakfast my whole day would be ruined
because
i feel like i just threw in the towel
early and i'm not strong like i gave up
like
it's like if you like started walking on
a marathon in the first
mile and you're like i wanted to run as
far as i could and that's your
perfectionism failure
but let me tell you eating three meals a
day breakfast i am
by no means out of the woods and
sometimes i'm just like i don't like
today i did i probably had 300 calories
for breakfast because i just wasn't that
hungry
and i'm i mean even to like be like i'm
i i don't
i'd rather eat it now the fact that it's
just the emotional energy that it takes
to do something when you just see
someone like
like picking everything and eating it
like doing what they're doing you're
like i know the amount of emotions
coming out
is so exhausting it's becoming that for
me and yesterday was the first time i
saw it i turned down
i turned down hot ones you know that
show hot ones i turned that
fucking juggernaut of a pr
move down when it was early on before it
was what it was but it was still like
you didn't want to because i didn't
want to eat i was on i was on quest bars
at that time in my life
and it wasn't a brownie quest bar
and i knew and i just didn't want to eat
those and they were like they'll make
them vegan i'm just like
it's the breading the like the sugar and
the sauces like and
that that still bugs me to say that my
eating disorder was taking from my
career
i mean i was fainting on stage i wasn't
i wasn't happy i was always hungry
but yesterday on this food show i it
didn't even occur to me to not do a show
about fast food which was
literally arsenic to me for the past 20
years
or so like fast food is just like you
can't have it anymore it's like a
like i was an alcohol like made that
rule for myself and so yesterday when i
i didn't even plan on saying like
saying anything about my eating disorder
on the show but i was like i start
talking
i go what's your history of fast food i
was like i loved it as a kid and i
it's the devil to me now and i go and i
go i never let myself have it i'm
excited to be here and i go actually
it's only the devil to me because i was
anorexic
i almost died from it and it became like
i literally thought it was poison and
i've never recovered from that
view of it and today is the first time
since i've been
you know recover recovering from an
eating disorder that i'm eating
like fast food because i don't usually
crave it but the whole and i was a
little bit worried the whole day like
having to be on this food show
it was so funny whitney they were all
like you're the fucking best
you eat everything and i go what it
wasn't a lot of food i go who the fuck
does this show like
i go you've had on so many sellers
everyone just takes a bite and they go
the chefs were like it's it's annoying
because people will take one bite and go
i don't really like and i was like
scooping it off we know what they're in
like do you know what i'm saying but
that's the thing that's that's the norm
and i go it should be the norm that
someone can finish three bowls of food
where i i didn't eat lunch either
because i wanted to be hungry enough for
the
the meals and it was like it just was
wild to me that i've
now gone from and i felt a little bit
insecure that i was like everyone's like
she can eat and i'm like i don't i
always was the girl that
was skinny and like i don't restrict it
i get the same about eating too much
because i want i think people are going
like
oh she's pretending she eats a lot like
and she's gonna go throw this up like
she's trying to be the cool fun girl and
i'm like god that's why i was eating so
fast i was like i was just so
nervous about the fact that they might
be judging me that i'm probably start i
mean
you probably already think i'm
anorexically i'm just wrong and you
think that because i used to do that in
reality no one's thinking about you
they're just shooting their shows
so no one's thinking they're worried i
wish they were because i would have
gotten help sooner if people pointed out
no one
cares no one cares like uh let's all
talk about this one thing that like no
we think about that all the time so we
assume everyone else that's like georgia
yes my therapist always says she's
always like we
you obsess over what people think about
you until that you realize they're not
i know that's thinking about themselves
and their insecurities you fucking
narcissists like
it's it's um sarah silverman i think's
uh pointing this out once the idea well
it's a big thing we say in 12-step
programs of
um uh like sarah says in one time when
people i hate myself i hate myself
you're still just talking about yourself
it's still narcissism it's myself myself
myself
and how in 12-step programs it's this
this balance between
self-loathing and narcissism which is
like i'm a piece of shit it's the center
of the universe
it's the best and one thing i just want
to say because i think it's important
like
this is an adage that like helped me a
lot in terms of like i know the things
that i won't be able to stop if i start
them
i can put a drink down fucking no
problem i yeah whatever it was with
edibles like that was just a thing i
could not stop my
i wrote a whole fucking book about the
eating disorder stuff so i don't want to
yeah yeah i know if i'm just how what i
did i
yeah i love aca like just that program
like help me and whatever a lot of other
things but
i um basically i feel like my workaholic
addiction
uh eclipsed my eating uh shit because i
couldn't work because
it's hard so i was like fuck it i'm just
getting whatever i want so i need to be
able to make all this money
when taylor swift uh got uh recovered
from her eating disorder or i don't know
what she found but like she
obviously was like very thin during a
time in her life
and then now it looks like a woman that
she's now
she's put on weight but like she
acknowledged in her documentary she was
like
i just thought you were supposed to at
the end of a arena show
feel like you wanted to die like i
didn't know it was because i was
malnourished and like she's like
now i'm like get done with these i still
have energy and it was like yeah you
just
and and i bet she's a workaholic i bet
she was like
this is actually being skinny isn't
helping my career
enough more than it's hurting it and not
that that she probably wants to afford
her own well i realized
when it affects your work when i started
fainting on stage i was like okay i
gotta start eating jesus christ
when you start eating after that you're
like oh my god you have a bagel and
you're like i feel like i'm calling
cocaine
you're like no that's just energy
everyone gets to feel like crazy but um
the one thing that this helped me just
like platitudes
outages aphorisms like they do help me
something that's like smart and catchy
and like
like just perfectly succinctly like and
memorably says something so
if i know if i text this guy up
he's gonna text back i'm like this i'm
just sending those one text to say
i'm done with you and then he's a text
back and i'm gonna fucking
now i'm really like i know that texting
this one x
one text will be two years of my life if
i'm lucky
right and the it's but i can text other
people and not respond all the time this
one person i know that
is your it is one too many a million not
enough
one too many a million dollars that's
the way i am with pot now like i'm
waiting for a bottom with it
they keep going why do you want a bad
bottom i go because honestly my bottoms
aren't ever that bad and i'm just not
right i'm not
i mean you know what we need a lot of
proof brains like we need
some people need a lot of i you don't
have enough proof i don't yet i'm not
saying i don't have my data and like you
have i'm jane goodalling myself and i'm
hiding out in the woods and i'm watching
my behavior with the pot i'm keeping i'm
putting up a system where i don't get to
hide it anymore i'm
learning things right now she was in
there getting high with the the yeah
she was working jane goodall was
observing the
the chips smoking weed she just needed
to smoke that's why they were ripping
off people's faces it made them
aggressive
his process is different she had to go
to the woods and then she was like hey
she was so stoned she was like hey guys
you can like read and write huh
[Laughter]
i bet jane goodall fucking gets down we
now take another
jarring startling break big
pivot to talk about our new sponsor ship
station we are passionate about shipping
our products
to fans and emily and benton
made a video about our shipping
department
before ship station things were really
hard here at whitney's
we had to work and work shipping
everything tirelessly
wondering when it would be over when we
could stop wiping tears
and really start living packaging was
just becoming too much it was
overwhelming and we didn't know what to
do
i mean look at how hard this is i can
barely put this
book in this envelope it's really
frustrating
for dinner we did whatever we could to
survive living off scraps
making sure we can make it to the next
day to ship our books
it was really difficult but together me
and emily made it through
sometimes we would get eggs emily didn't
like that oh my god
oftentimes we get an extra blueberry and
we get really upset about it because
it's unfair only one of us gets it other
than that we just spend our time reading
the bible
trying to make the best of the situation
we were in
every night we wondered will this be our
last night will we wake up to an easier
shipping situation
than some of us did shipstation is a
dream come true
it's the number one choice of online
sellers no matter how i sell shipstation
funnels all my orders into one simple
interface that i can manage from
anywhere
even my cell phone i'm so thankful to
have a cell phone now
i bet if we had a cell phone we could
have saved benton
he could have made it i know he would
love shipstation
italy oh well whole new world
oh my god you should see the the amount
of footage i have of emily gagging over
that egg
astronomical all right well we'll have
to put that in for i don't know
or next i only know our next blue chew
out if this didn't work for you
if emily got an egg doesn't get you an
erection i don't know what will
ship more in less time for a lot less
money just use my offer code whitney to
get a 60 day
free trial that's two months free of no
hassle
stress free shipping just go to
shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the page and type in whitney that's
shipstation.com
enter offer code whitney make ship
happen and don't take shit from anyone
now we take a break from doing ads to do
another ad
but before i get into that i have
questions benton and emily why
why aren't you two dressed up like the
best fiends characters this week
i thought we were gonna do that every
week you dress up like the slug you just
have like the ladybugs
just like you can't possibly be done
with playing the fun
engaging casual mobile puzzle game
we are not we took it to a whole new
level yeah we would never be done
there's only one place left to go
only fiends do you love best fiends
the matching puzzle game with over 100
million downloads
and over thousands of fun puzzles to
solve
free to download best fiends
the match 3 or casual mobile puzzle game
best feeds i can't put it down
i'm obsessed it's fun
and engaging best things
casual gameplay that fits perfectly into
your life
do you enjoy best fiends collectible
characters
unlocking new worlds and making 30
minutes feel like
30 seconds do you love slugs
bugs strawberries
mushrooms water droplets
flowers and unlocking new
characters i play so much
best feeds i'm on level 69.
but do you ever want to take a break
after playing
best speeds all day and
leveling up your bugs and defeating your
slugs
then come on down to only fiends
tonight come have some xx extra fun
on this special version only
fiends are you ready for a sexier side
of
best fiends then join us at
only fiends best fiends free to download
only fiends only on good for you
only things is not associated with best
things in any way shape or form it's
completely made up good for you
production and is not at all endorsed by
best fiends which is a wonderful game
we're so sorry you had to see this
please go download best fiends for free
today
once again only things are all
associated with best fiends in any way
shape or form is completely made up good
food production is not alone
by best things which is a wonderful
there's a first for everything and today
i can honestly say i am speechless
you have two options you can either
subscribe to our only fiends or you can
download only best fiends one of the two
i'm still
without speech but i'm gonna i'm gonna
charge ahead anyway
and find a way to tell you without
speech did we fix you i'm speechless
i'm speechless from that sizzle from
that
hot sizzle so you can download
best fiends you can down this you can
only get
best fiends only fiends here on good for
you that is an exclusive
but if you go get best fiends the five
star rated puzzle game
you'll be able to understand their only
fiends better so it's where you know
what i'm saying it's like when i saw the
second fifty shades of grey and not the
first i was like what's happening like i
can't follow this
you'll never know the back story you
have to know the back story exactly so
why don't you go and download the five
star rated puzzle game best fiends free
today on the app store
or google play that's friends without
the r
best fiends but only fiends is what they
are
the one thing that i want to say that
really you know some of these things
that you get when you're recovering
like you just are like well that's it
that cracked it open for me i heard
something so great the other day and
this is why i'm approaching
it with food and with because i still
have little things with food that i'm
like
i want to starve myself or i want to
exercise tomorrow because i overate
today and by the way
anything about like starving yourself
applies to overeating
and like stuff so this is like i hope
people in this conversation are like
this is only about this one
no you're overeating by the way because
you're starving yourself in other ways
and be
or be because it's an emotional thing it
could be
you have nine cups of coffee a day but
everything else is normal
in the way that you eat or you only eat
it in your car
or whatever it is how many eating
disorders there are out there and how
disordered eating you can also say i've
disordered eating if it sounds itchy but
when i see someone who's obese
i know exactly i don't know exactly what
they're going through
but i know that i have the same disease
as them it just manifests differently
all i know is that when i was anorexic
at the worst of it i did get treated
differently i i that's why i'm a
community i always tell the story but
i'm a community because i was i i looked
like a legit
holocaust victim when i went to my
freshman year of college i didn't have
any friends the only way to make friends
was to be
larger than life with personality to
make them forget that i looked
so fucking frightened i mean look i look
at pictures and i'm like how did
anyone let this girl walk into like go
i mean it's wild that i survived and
thank god but the only reason i survived
it was because i discovered comedy and i
was like
fuck i gotta like survive to like i'm
good at something finally
other than starving myself but the thing
is i
really really like i've learned through
recovering from an eating disorder and
really like
going into it that um you think that an
anorexic and a obese person
are like couldn't be more opposite it is
the exact same thing
and let me tell you the pendulum will
swing i remember when
this eating disorder lady before i was
going to college sat my mom down and
said
nikki um should not go to college she's
going to die
and um she i remember she goes what if
your roommate's skinnier than you and i
was like
there's no way because i was like 90
pounds or so like i was like
like this is a little tidbit that i
learned that i really think will help
everyone start going with addiction
because it's a food related thing
but i'm really applying it to pot
because i have a lot of guilt around pot
and that's why i like to talk about it
so much because i'm struggling with it
but i heard a story one time of someone
with an eating disorder that is
recovered and she was talking about
getting
cookies which were her fucking alcohol
right
shouldn't have um probably no probably a
red light food in terms of like i
shouldn't have that
she had them she was getting them for a
party and she's driving home did you say
a red light food
yeah is that a that's a term yeah it's
like that that means like
can't have it ever like a lot don't have
it never again so in some in some
programs you would say bottom line like
my bottom line is i never
i never do this thing i never have sex
unless they're my boyfriend i've never
okay so red light red light food yellow
light food is like
listen like maybe like i'm not gonna go
buck wild but we know the foods where
you go you just can't have one yes yes
got it and thinking about a life without
those foods i'm sure
anyone that's hearing this is like i'm
not going to give up that thing that i
like to like that's interesting
so red light behavior okay so sorry just
yeah and behaviors i have read like
behaviors
i think it's good that people know this
because it's like there are certain you
might be hearing us going i can have one
protein bar and put it down
but i can't have one milkshake and put
it like but you could also hear that and
go
i'm never going to put down a milkshake
and then you're turning off the podcast
right here just wait
here we go hearing other people's uh
bottom lines or red light
things are fascinating to me because we
get to make them specifically for
ourselves and a lot of mine are so weird
because i know but i love shopping i
love
them a lot of people go into uh 12 set
rooms and they hear someone going oh my
bottom line is that's my and they go
well i don't belong here it's like no no
no and sometimes you hear it you go
i didn't even know that was a thing you
could not do and i don't think i need
that
i and they can be as simple as i don't
go
on reddit from four to five in the
morning or whatever yeah
but uh when i went to i went to a
workaholics anonymous meeting once
it was kind of hilarious because
everyone was 20 minutes late
rushing from work everyone was on their
phone
many of the people were like known
people because they're overachieving
people
and it was like literally i two of them
i'm like oh my god i love your work
no keep doing it i want more i love your
work
which the worst thing you can say to
someone who's trying to work less and
then
um one person's bottom line in their
workaholism
was when i have to pee i'll get i will
not hold my pee
oh wow which is like a thing that i
realized i totally do if i'm like
working on something i have to pee i
just fucking i'm like i'll do it
and it almost makes you feel good
because you're like there's like when i
would feel hungry i would feel alive
from it
or a sense of like a sense of something
letting me know what i'm doing i'm doing
something
hard that i'm not even going to i'm
fighting through pain like i'm tough
but i'm better but you're it's making
you distracted and it's
ruining your bladder and gonna cause you
income by the way no one
like after you like don't pee for three
out no one like shows up with a check
being like you held your p the longest
like what's this four
that's such an interesting one and like
yeah one of those light bulb moments
where you go oh my god i didn't even
realize i was doing that but you see it
so this girl was talking about she was
bringing home cookies for a party or for
a thing next day and she
she was like i'll have one you know like
we all do the one then it's
okay two is fine then three it turns out
to be a row right she sees the row and
she's disgusted with herself she
just sees the row the row she eats the
entire row of oreos
the sleeve the sleeve yeah she and
there's a bunch more but she ate the
whole row
way more than she wanted to have then
and she's like
fuck i'm such a fucking fat lazy ass i
wasn't supposed to eat that row how am i
even gonna explain this disgusting
the admonishment that went on for the
the row
guess what that turned into the bag so
if
she would have just let herself off the
hook for the row the bag
she was already she was already stopped
at the row and and stopped to
beat herself up for the row which then
turned into the bag the bag wouldn't
have happened
it's already you would have just let
yourself go for the row so when i
do not like to cut our losses what we
like to make our losses more extreme
but what what is doing that is the self
abuse that you put on yourself when so
when i smoke pot
and i don't go the other day i've been
playing guitar and i always record
myself
when i'm practicing because i just want
to see my progress which
i haven't seen it but i was watching the
other day i left i suddenly left my
computer on
and you see me i hear me like put down
my guitar and i'm like
my shoulder hurts i'm like like in my
room it's kind of cute to hear yourself
like be funny you're like oh my god i'm
cute like cute and funny like i'm
adorable like i love myself i am lovable
i was being so cute i was like my
shoulders numb and i was in that i could
hear myself in my bathroom i remember
what i was doing
because then i walked back to my laptop
to go bring it into the kitchen that's
also pure inner child shit
yeah there's a poster of taylor swift on
the wall that i put up because i haven't
gotten it framed yet that i literally
put up with tape and i'm like fuck it
i'm not gonna wait to be an adult i want
a taylor swift poster on my wall that
inspires me
i'm putting it up so they're in the
background you see a taylor swift i'm
like
my my shoulder is numb my shoulders then
you hear me go like you hear this
taking a breath hear me light light pot
i like you know take a hit
and then i in my head i remember going
you shouldn't be smoking pot right now
and then i just go remember the the
sleeve you just ate a sleeve
of cookies you didn't want to do that
right now you have to get on a call in a
minute why'd you do that
i thought of it as the sleeve of cookies
and i went from going
you did it you broke the seal now just
have it all i go i picked up my laptop
i'm going in this i picked up my pot too
and i go and you hear me go
i'm grateful for pot to help me in this
moment where i feel anxious
i'm grateful for my hands i'm great i
start doing a gratitude list
but i instead of going i literally
stopped myself i was so
proud of myself watching myself do this
because i went from i go i'm
i said i'm grateful for pot i'm grateful
for that thing that i just felt guilt
about
i'm so happy that it helped me in this
moment that i needed it
i don't need more and because i was kind
to myself i didn't smoke more that time
and sometimes you do smoke more but it's
so much you like gave yourself a hug to
be like
i forgive myself so when i just think
that when i think it could help people
because it's helped me
when you have that first sign of you
disgusting fat
piece of shit you lazy or drug addicted
or whatever it is dummy
wrong texting that guy or you stay it
can be about anything yes
say try to laugh at it and try to go
that is so sweet that that is
you're only trying to do the best for
yourself like i when i first realized
like
if i wish my ass looked different i
really do i have the flat ass and i
i wish that it looked like yours you
know i
if i could stop my fingers it would
right yes but just stay with me uh you
have an amazing amazing took us and i
was last time i got to see your boobs
this time i was just like watching your
ass as you showed me around your
you're like in the arch ceiling and i'm
just like looking at your butt being
like
it's so good what does she do that i'm
not doing i
i i wish i could have your butt and if i
could set my fingers and have it i would
but all this that would take for me to
have that but i can't do it
i can't i don't want to do the the
classes i don't i don't want to do it
and i'm not actively choosing that
people always think
well i'm lazy so i'm actively choosing
to be a lazy
and i'm fat because i don't run it's
like you if you could step your fingers
you would be
there's something going on that you
can't you can't do it right now and be
okay with that you can't do it you're
not
trying to be fat right now you're not
trying to be an addict
you're trying no one wakes up and says
today i'm going to be an
addict that sabotages my entire life and
hurts the people around
no one it took me two years in alana to
realize that someone else's
addiction wasn't in a personal attack on
me because i had my own addictions etc
and i
and so it's like that took me so long to
learn and what you're saying is also
reminding me to say oh this is when
people like 12
sub programs are stupid yeah we all
agree
no one wants to go to a 12-step program
i mean i know helena bottom carter in
like
fight club like would go for her or
whatever no one's like i really wanted
for four days a week bring coffee to an
abandoned church and sit with a bunch of
fucking people that
no one like wants you do it because you
you know that what works about it is in
that moment where you say
i'm really thinking about doing heroin i
i fucking texted my ex today and that
was a relapse for me and now i'm gonna
you get to go into a room and and that
exact moment you're talking about
where you you can have compassion where
you can fork and you can say acceptance
i'm going to i i had that fucked up
thought i hate myself
i could either go recoil deeper into my
disease to anesthetize that shame which
is the which keeps compounding and
comment pounding because i'm keeping it
secret
or i can have smart feet and get in the
fucking car
and go to a place where i go you guys i
want to eat that second
sleeve of cookies and everyone goes oh
my god you're amazing you fucking
admitted that because that is the
bravest shit to fucking do and a bunch
of strangers
and then everyone is going like i want
to do that yeah and then you get to
dissipate the shame which takes away the
need
to hurt yourself again it's that's
absolutely getting rid of the bullying
yourself having that
really everyone says be nice to yourself
talk to yourself like a friend it's not
that easy
it takes so much time to practice that's
why i was so excited that i heard myself
do it
in that moment i was like it's finally
clicking for you you don't have to be
you have to be reminded of it later and
it doesn't always click but when i just
can stop and say
nikki you did go on bill maher and you
said a joke that was
that you had a punchline for that you
didn't get to why did you tell that joke
out of all the ones that you had planned
to talk about why did you do that dumb
one that's only
gonna be misunderstood because you
didn't get to finish your point and then
i would say why are you thinking to do
that joke why did they why did you sneak
you idiot why did you say that joke you
would rehearse what you were gonna do
why in that moment because you know what
that was all i had in the moment used to
fucking spiral
after every appearance of like why did i
say that and this is not just podcasts
if you like have you know experiences
why did i say that to my sister why did
i say that to the person at the grocery
store why was i talking about
my bra why would i mention my bra
that voice of admonishment you didn't
want to talk about your bra to that
neighbor that was like
kind of creeped out by the fact that you
mentioned whatever it was you didn't
want to do that
if you could have chosen differently but
you didn't but also there's a i remember
i went to um dr david agus who has been
on this podcast oh yeah
the brain doctor who oh he was the one
that made that and that's andrew
huberman no no no he
uh aegis does a lot of stuff of like
brain imaging to see if the blood flow
to the brain okay got it to make sure
like
pretty much everything is like your
blood in your brain he's just like the
cartoon marvel uh justin bieber's guy
who does everything yeah i don't know
he's like the guy and he um i had to
mute him because he was making me feel
bad about swinging pop
because he was like it makes me less
blood to your brain i should feel that i
need that information
unmuted and i will unmute him when i'm
ready to have more
tickets as long as i can i don't care
yes you are
you are you've been busy girl that is
literally like i must say when people
like when do you know you've made it and
you're like when i hosted this or when i
got the special it's like when nikki
glazer
oh my god you're so funny and like
beautiful i just i'm captivated i love
your clips and it's i like
i really love you and i am so
everyone wants to everyone likes to talk
shit right in this business and you were
someone that was very easy and is still
very easy to talk shit about because
you are so right now more than ever
you are so yourself you don't give a
fuck like you just you literally don't
give a fuck
you are not trying to dress for anyone
else you're at least that i love it by
the way i love that
that is a compliment i know it sounds
like an insult but it's so funny you
i just used to do a joke about that
where someone come and be like i just
love that you like don't even like i
hear what you look like i'm like i've
been making for too much no you work in
hair makeup but like you are in that
because
you know what looks good i can't you
know how you want to look
and maybe the only reason i got hair and
makeup today or i got makeup and
whatever
is because i know this is gonna be a big
episode oh i
i give fucks i you do give fucks but
that's the thing is like
people wanna people i'm not and i i
wouldn't even name names but like
you were discussed a lot in the comedy
community because you are so successful
and because now this whitney that we all
we all got used to talking shit about
the whitney that
seemed to try to get everyone to like
her and was doing a great job of it
for for you know until you just
chose a different lifestyle exactly but
now you're a whitney that
people are going she's a little whoa
it's a lot
it's because she's actually operating
from a place of doing
whatever saying whatever no no here's
why it's a lot here's why it's a lot
to people because i'm now talking for
three hours
a fucking week and you see me on tv once
a year
it's a lot like what do you mean it's a
lot like that no i
think it's a lot because it's like you
want blue hair and so everyone thinks
that somehow like uh
the state of your mental health actually
that to me is like someone and not no
one's singing that i'm just saying like
hold on decisions like that that women
make and people freak out people want to
say that you're like when she has no
hair she's crazy i was so much fucking
crazier when i was a brunette i know
that's my
entire twenties it's for me i look at
you and i'm so
glad to be friends with you because i
can read through the book you're not
fixed i have you i sell freedom that is
free
and by the way you didn't like me when i
was supernatural you didn't like me when
i had blue hair you didn't like you oh
you never liked me has nothing to do
with my hair changing it has nothing to
do with anything
hearing that you might be uh difficult
to work with calculating you know the
same kind of thing like you're very
taylor swifty like where people
want to pin your success on calculation
which like oh she
had a forethought and decided to do
something i am abs if if that
is a good word i know i like no but like
we need calculus women that are like
ambitious or calculating is like gross
and it's like
it doesn't mean i don't have talent or
worse thirsty for fame and
by the way maybe you should be more
calculated why the fuck are you it to me
i think it's just a plan by the way we
should all be more calculating comedians
calculate
calculate more yeah so that you have
fucking health insurance yeah i'm sorry
i had seven dollars and i had five
family members with no health insurance
i had to be calculated i had no choice
or i wouldn't be able to do this so it's
like like like let's
take the stigma off planning two days in
advance like let's
and by the way at that time guess what
part of being successful at that time
maybe it's still this way yes i had to
calculate and introduce myself and say
hi and be
like that's what you had to do yeah and
it worked so i like
it is what it is i i i i'm yeah i'm not
saying that that
now i can calculate now i calculate
absences instead of presences but at a
time
where i had to like like hang out at the
comedy store for four hours
so that i could fucking get on stage i
had to hang out at an open mic so that i
could calculate
absences i more now try to calculate
absences which is like
i just think that i think i just kind of
realized like just with like
stuff now people have access to you all
the time they can go on youtube and
watch
oh you calculate when i'm going to go
away as opposed to what i'm going to be
you can be overexposed right now just
because someone's in a wormhole of all
your videos i know
that's the biggest fear it's like it's
like i want to be able to do everybody's
podcast i want to but i i calculate
absences that are just like
i don't want to go to podcast and tell
us like if i've already i have nothing
to say right now
i got to start right now like i just got
to do less in general because i'd rather
just the stuff i'm proud of be out there
and not be like like just doing talk
shows for that because
because a lot of talkers want to have us
on all the time because we're funny and
we're always going to name it no i say
yes to fucking you can't join rivers but
it's also
it's also you're getting paid 20 million
dollars i'm getting paid
i'm probably losing money doing this and
i'm going to put a day of work into it
and it doesn't really benefit me that
much i'm going to spend that time on
putting work into my own podcast
my show why am i why i only do stuff i
want to do now like
it's because it's truly going to be fun
or it's going to be like it has a big
enough following that
justifies it or but otherwise i tell
people i go you don't have enough
followers
and it's i don't have enough time and
i'm sorry to say that i'm going to be
honest with you
but what i will say is that don't have
followers i go because i like you so
much and i just want to hang out with
you you know yeah totally but there are
things like in terms of social media i
am very calculated about i used to be
like i don't bad word fuck
that was a word that got tossed around
about you that could dismiss your talent
because
she's just she works hard yeah the work
hard thing i know you
you have issue with too because i hate
that too when people go you know what
nikki i'm glad you got that
because i said to that person she works
so hard and i go it's just such a
thing it's such a dismissal okay you
know what that is what i do i have a
talent for working hard so
look into it so if working really hard
makes you me
how come you don't do it exactly so so
why the talent is working hard but
it's like and i'm bringing up because i
do believe that most talent is
when people like dane cook isn't funny
all right one this was when he was doing
arenas it was like massive
so when people go dan cook isn't funny
it's like dane cook's not funny he's not
funny and he's making 30 million dollars
a year so what's your excuse if you are
funny
what you do what i'm saying i'm like
what where's no because people are dumb
and they want things that aren't funny
and my
uh that's their experience but i know
what i'm doing when i say shit like that
and i'm trying to make myself feel
better and so to me i remember and neil
brennan said this to me once in the
hallways ages ago
he goes uh we were talking about like
managers or something and he goes if i
was a
comedy manager i would just go into
comedy clubs and
ask the comedians who they hated and
then sign that person that's such
that's great that's it so i'm like it's
to me and then i'd have the convenience
who they love and i'd hire that person
to write then i learned
then i learned if comedians hate me i
must be doing well
so when i felt it and i felt that hatred
negativity i was like oh i must be doing
well and guess what y'all fucked up and
made me stronger also
yeah so it's like if i can go into a
fucking comedy hallway
knowing all these comedians fucking hate
me and then still do my job and drive
home like
you guys toughened me up because later i
had to fucking run a show
and deal with shit like that so you
accidentally made me stronger well
trying to take me down because i talked
a lot today about you you you are
welcome
was it is it it was just that you were
that you were calculated it was all
about like
she doesn't deserve that she tries to
art she just she's uh
she's just smoothed away you know like
all those things like that's yeah kind
of the i just
i just i wanted to hear anyone say
anything about you that i could
use as a way to realize why you got
things and i didn't because
it and it couldn't be because you're
funnier or because you
laugh when in reality me getting
something i don't deserve means oh my
god then i'm going to get twice as much
as her because i do deserve it
that would be the thing it should make
you go holy shit but
i knew and i didn't exactly i just
didn't i don't
you were successful because you i didn't
have what you had like
you're special but i wanted to kind of
tell you oh my god but i also want to
want to
uh uh just the smooching thing real
quick just because people
like i think are thinking yeah tell me
tell me what schmoozing
it it it doesn't work like i that i
actually never did like i wanted to be
seen by the people
who needed to know i existed and the art
of seduction by robert green i did read
it i did absolutely
stuff i saw in the book where it's like
you run into people and you like
introduce yourself and then i'm gonna
kind of oh like i do know as well i'm
gonna ask about his wife because i don't
want him to think i'm flirting with him
like i
i was very calculated about being a
young woman in hollywood
like having business relationships with
men at 25
and not i would like pretend i was
engaged i would like ask about the what
i would be like
you know i would work very hard to make
sure they didn't see me as a potential
like a person to prey on and a business
woman and so like i was very calculated
what i want
a woman never dress sexy well do you
begrudge a woman who does use that to
get ahead
in the story and sleeps with someone to
get a roll i don't either not in the
slightest
fuck you want as long as it's consensual
i don't care if you get the thing and
then you bomb
you won't do it again it's like if you
have the talent if you get that role
it doesn't work though that's the thing
exactly that's what it is if a director
if fucking directors would get me in
movies in my 20s i absolutely would have
done it i fucked way worse people than
directors
i know like i'm like i'm the one running
fucking like
guys that live in their cars ever so for
me
i'm gonna sleep with the wrong people in
my 20s if i get a fucking job and money
out of it
why not pick a better bad one my god but
it doesn't work because
because usually it's like oh i
i've seen so many girls be like i'm
dating this director and then and it's
like no they got you
now they're gonna say and that's not how
it works you cannot go to a studio and
say
i really want to hire my girlfriend
actually you're less likely to get hired
if you're dating a director because
they're like well she
they don't want to deal with that stigma
so that doesn't work i'm not saying that
it should or
i'm not i don't have a judgment on i'm
saying what works and what doesn't take
the emotion and the judgment and the
sexism out of it
the same thing with like schmoozing i
learned like
it comes off desperate you have to be
i didn't realize until i was on the
other side of auditioning
that when someone comes in and it's like
hey nice to meet you and like wants your
approval it's
so repellent is there anything grosser
to
human race than someone who's desperate
needy it's the more people pleasing we
are it's like
the more unattractive it's like the
irony is we're pushing the person away
that we're trying to
and then i would look on uh sheets of
actors they give you a list of all the
actors that are coming to audition
you'll be like oh i saw her at that
motorola party last night like
it degrades you it degrades your value
if you are
too visible and around people too much
because they're like well this person
doesn't fucking work like
being enigmatic and like having right
which gave me which gave me the freedom
to go oh i don't have to fucking
schmooze great i can just go fucking
work and write scripts and learn and
write jokes
so you saw that side of it and got to
see that
you you were you you were someone to
schmooze and you saw that the schmoozing
didn't work on you and so you go
but i would have done it if it did but i
think it's important that people know
that it doesn't
right so because a lot of people need a
network no no just work do not network
just work networking true and be kind
along the way
because that that to me is like i can't
believe
people who can be terrible people uh
and and become but not fake don't be
fake don't be fake but just be
yeah don't be just be honest yeah but
like i don't think anybody
in general just talk less uh like we are
telling us
oh i know what i'm saying like in works
we're the only business where people
just like are like
hang out at parties that don't really
employ each other but could maybe like
it's just like such a boundary-less
shit show i just want to say something
really quick because before we have to
go just to wrap up
the the thing about dave because i do
want to hear all the other shit you
talked about me
and the i've never you know i just want
to say right now when so uh so recently
there was some someone i just could say
was like
planting your name in a way that was
like i'll get nikita like maybe it was
someone i maybe talk to
like i can't even think of who it was
because i don't remember because it was
it was just such a nice moment it was
someone that i
probably would want to like me like in
that moment i have to stand next to them
so i want their approval would have been
so easy for me to just go
yeah like if they want to talk about you
just go like nod my head and not feel
like i was betraying you but
it's so nice and it's only maybe because
i have a career enough that i can
take a stand but i don't think that's it
like i love
being able to defend
people or to say actually that's not
what that person is at all and i know
that from personal experience
and here's why you think that and here's
why that's not true and to have them
never first of all talk like that or try
to plant that again
but like i'm just such a plus in my life
i've fucking swallowed so many times
when i heard people talk shit about
things that i care about
and i just don't let it slide anymore
and it feels great and it's not just you
it's it's you know
here's i would i'm not telling you not
to do whatever you want to do
i'm not saying like i deserve a gold
star for defending you and by the way it
does not happen
uh often but there was just a chance
that someone else people know were from
no friends now so they wouldn't do
but this person didn't know anything let
me tell you two things let me tell you
two things number one
when you when i hear there's someone at
the at a comedy venue
a comic talking shit about me when i'm
not even there i'm like
you're killing it damn exactly comes up
even when i'm not there oh i
you know i'm saying that because i know
what it means when a bunch of people
talk shit about someone
that you know i know what jealousy looks
like whatever i'm not saying people are
jealous of me but like i
i'm sure they talked about ten thousand
talk about you on stage i have this bit
about you right now
it's so i s because the the bit is i
revealed i go
yeah no thank oh i go thanks for that
whitney
and i and and everyone knows because i
go i asked a comic friend of mine this
thing and then i say the thing
it's about what i think i talked about
on your show but when i said i was going
to shave my head and you were like
you look amazing do it i'm not talking
about how when you're did i go when i
wanted to cut my bangs
everyone all my friends were like are
you okay but when i want to shave my
head whitney's like
do it your bone structure you were just
being nice but i'm like i go jess
switzer who colors my hair
has a shaved head and they're so fucking
gorgeous and hot
but i will be shaving my head back i
wanted to shave my head and whitney's
like do it and i go
uh you're a bad friend
i go
it's so fun to do you because i love
that you're that
famous and uh you know if someone knows
me they know you and it's just so
fun to be able to take those things
where it's like
it's i'm i'm i'm doing a joke that
sounds like i'm talking shit about her
like
because then i go into the whole thing
of like but if you really were you
couldn't do the joke if we weren't real
friends
yeah and and can i say one more thing
about this because i think this is
an important tool that i use where if i
want if someone wants to come to me and
gossip about
which is very often like people want to
be able to go well whitney said this and
then
use gossiping with me against me later
it'll be like see she's an asshole so
i know exactly what i'm being made and
i'm also just a
like whatever i'm also a a well forgive
that person they must be hurt they must
be injured like i always defend the
people that people want to
talk about me even if they fucking hurt
me so um
uh i'm a shitty person to gossip with
but if someone comes up to me and it's
like hey so like nikki like
you know like just trying to bait like
let's see like mickey
nicky's latest post yeah like that yeah
whatever and instead of going what the
fuck are you doing because that person
is all right they're not gonna hear what
i'm saying because they already feel the
need to gossip about somebody and
they're shitty so me
saying this now they just have ammo to
go whitney's fucking crazy she just
yelled at me in the hallway
and so uh my thing the only thing i will
say
yeah what do you do besides like ignore
it and go i can either say
um i don't focus that much on other
people's instagrams or whatever like
something passive aggressive a little
shitty i normally go like
why do you feel the need to bring this
up that's good or what's going on with
you
that you're so focused on that see i
wanted to go
i see why you would say that and think
that because i once thought the same all
right i once had a preconceived notion
of someone that i thought i knew because
we were friends
but i've gotten to know her and can i
just and not even defend you but be like
there are multi this we we are all
whitney
and can i tell you something is me and
you are whitney and we are all whitney
and she's just fucking honest and that's
what i love about her and she can do
whatever the goddamn fuck she wants and
i'm gonna keep watching it and like i'm
inspired
can i tell you something else this is
the other thing so let's um
uh shit talk about nikki glazier me to
talk about yeah like
a gossip about yourself with me about oh
my god did you see like
we get it like you're single and sad and
she's like
so orange she's like sally hansen in her
arms we can see it sloughing off
still with the spray tans have you seen
a key glazer she's like orange all the
time
dude i don't know but whatever she is
doing is fucking working because she has
a huge theater tour and she's hosting
all these shows and she's supposed to be
fucking boys like
whatever she's doing i might start doing
that then oh that's really good
what i'm saying because there's also
that it's like that's the spirit of what
i
always say because i just want to be
around you and maybe you become more
maybe you gossipy shitty per maybe you
should go get a spray tan
maybe you should do whatever the fuck
she's doing because it's obviously
working i do admire you and like look up
to you and i think you're so cool and
but today i was coming over like
worrying about what i'm gonna wear is
whitney going to be like
your hair what's this story what oh
we're supposed to shave it what's the
story we're seeing why am i seeing
you've done that to me before since
we've been
close friends again and i was worried
coming in but like the thing is i never
that's i i have all the i still have
preconceived notions and i get nervous
to come over to your big house and like
i hope she likes me and thinks the one
thing i really want to be friends with
it's not about like you're not
going to see you there are times like
melissa senor this sounds like i'm an
asshole
but when we uh she used to open for me
on the road and we were in vegas once
and
she's the most talented like you know
and she would do an impression of me on
stage
it would destroy so hard that i couldn't
follow it the real me
so um it was a tricky one people rather
see her doing the impression than
actually me showing up i'd come out
they'd be like
i'd have to call her back out like it
was embarrassing and so uh
one guy you have like a whitney off yeah
you like talk to yourself is that fun
i'm like can you just give her the check
like i don't deserve any of this
and um she uh i only exist so that she
can do the impression now i'm like
you know irrelevant but um she would and
she now i have no idea how she dresses
now whatever i know i dress in horse
shirts and i'm not known for my like
fashion forward approach all the time
but um yes you are but that's amazing
thank you but like um elizabeth would
come in in these like bell-bottom pants
and like boots like like old boots and
like sweaters and hoodies and i kind of
was like i'm not saying you can't dress
like this
but i just want to understand why no
you're a star
and i'm going to need you to start
acting like one not on my shows i'm not
working right she thinks that that's
what a star
dress that that's fine she'll be a star
regardless but i was like i just want
you
you're i just want you to know you're a
star and the things
like sometimes people just need
permission to go oh yeah i don't have to
minimize myself
yeah if you're not minimizing it that's
fine i see you as a star
and like i just want you to make sure
that you know that you know that you can
that you're perceived that will still
get everything you want
i know that when i when i was in my
twenties i thought
you have to wear a hoodie and a backpack
and like no makeup and yeah neuter
yourself and like oh i love that version
of you it's so not threatening
but and just the face that doesn't need
makeup and the hair and it didn't work
it doesn't it doesn't like me
you're you're just like oh my god i'm so
amazing no then it was like oh whitney's
trying to be a boy it's like there's
always
too much yeah i think what if i was
transitioning
it's just you can't win but i i do love
that like
i see you as a like just telling your
friend like just by the way like
you were you're you're a star and
sometimes you just need permission from
someone else
like and katherine ryan is who i got it
from but totally by accident
we were doing it's such an embarrassing
thing i love catherine ryan no dude
she was i was hosting a gala at montreal
and she was uh um
uh on it and she wears these like super
hyper feminine like doll dresses and
they're so fun and then she tells these
like
you know super smart filthy jokes and
she uh there was my
whatever passive aggressive like fucking
black all saints like
you know overpriced t-shirt and uh and
the
whoever it was the ad or whoever was
like pull out this like yellow
like snow white dress it was like is
this yours and i was like no
i would never wear that on stage and
katherine was in makeup right next to me
she told me the story way later
and we talked about it on ig live one
day because i was like so mortified
but it was i was like i i didn't feel
like i could ever do that i'm like i
could never wear i can't be feminine on
stage
i can't be sexy i'm not allowed to wear
dresses like that's not for me like
i i no one would take me seriously that
was all my shit
is katherine ryan going i'm gonna dress
like a fucking doll and have makeup on
and glitter and i'm still fucking funny
that's
coming in here that this was too low cut
and you were going to go we're not doing
sexy today because i think you did that
to me one time
you go no more sexy for like for you
like let's and
and and i and now you feel like it on
edibles
like it regardless it was just your
opinion and you could have been right
but i was like
i st this is embarrassing to admit and i
don't want you to feel like that
i feel weird around you or anything but
today i was like no matter what whitney
tries to give you in terms of like a new
wardrobe
just stick at like you wanna you feel
good in this this is what you decided
and you're gonna wear this even though i
all the free clothes you gave me i've
been wearing
constantly and i do if you have anything
to give me i would like to actually do
because it's it's a very sexy thing but
i when i walked in today all of that
went away the second i saw you and it
always does
because i i i'm i'm just saying like
i didn't even plan on telling you that
but the fact that i can makes me feel
like that's something i can't believe
i'm saying it on air but oh we'll cut it
i would be like really nervous
to tell you that in person but you have
to be able to tell your friends when
you're scared of that and i'm scared of
you sometimes and it's important to say
that i'm scared of me sometimes uh uh
which is weird because my only goal is
to protect you and make you safe
and sometimes i know i come off scared
but i know that now but to me i trust
and i'll say i'm going to blame the
victim here i don't believe women
um if you when you came in last time i
think i remember
unless i'm dysmorphic and misremembering
i think i remember you coming in and
being like i don't like i don't know if
i should wear this or this
yes no i was insecure and you were
helping those moments i just want
someone to tell me what to do
and i've been in situations on sets with
actresses they're like should i wear
this or this again
which one makes you happy and they're
like hey and they just want somebody to
go the blue one no because i think
you saw me in several things struggling
because i would get dressed up in these
sexy things and i wouldn't be as
comfortable you
you know you can see it in my early
stand-up sets i'm like wearing these
tiny dresses and heels like is this what
i'm supposed to wear
and now when i dress sexy i sometimes
feel guilt like oh
sexy equals uncomfortable nicky why
would you make yourself uncomfortable so
men like you are people like you
but now i realize like i haven't had sex
in two years i'm not trying to fucking
fuck anyone i'm this is not me trying to
be like you're also always
like me i just feel sexy and so good
there's the flaw in this this
the self-limiting belief that i hear is
you don't think you're sexy unless
you're showing skin
no i definitely do but i just think i
look fucking great in this shirt with
this color like
i like taking risks with my stand up
with uh why not take response fashion
when i express myself i've never allowed
myself to do that because i'm so worried
that someone might think that i'm trying
to be sexy
god first fucking bid as a single woman
i try to when i'm on tv remind men that
i'm a sexual being
so that i don't keep getting slides that
say you're the goat or
giving women watching you permission to
be sexy themselves yeah it's just for
men it is our job as comedians
to to take risks and do crazy shit yeah
and we are can i tell you we are first
and foremost we are fucking entertainers
it's is it entertaining or not are you
not entertained
like it is my job i don't need just a
microphone and my thoughts
it is our job to surprise people it is
our job to take risks be wild
people holy shit we are like people live
by cares to those it's our job to be
like the emotional sky divers to take
crazy risks like benton has really
helped me with this because i was like
i can't wear makeup i can't wear
eyeliner he's like why the fuck not yes
my hero
is someone named joan rivers who wore
gowns on stage
and fucking gold hats makeup all over
the fucking place we're like we all just
need to dress like the the
the comedians that do shitty rape jokes
that are featuring and can't that come
why it didn't work for you yeah what it
didn't work for you
my god i love this that's why i i i
think there's so few female comedians to
compare us to they were like we're
trying to still trail but
like sarah silverman wasn't the like
we're allowed to not
do exactly like what she did was perfect
for her and that's who she is but i was
always like oh you just have to dress
this way this is the only thing i had to
look to
yes i'm like where do i get that fucking
backpack she always has that is so cute
like i later
i tried to do this she is on and off
stage what she wants to wear
all the time i sometimes don't know what
i don't guess what she also i remember
one time seeing her at the
something there's a lot of times when
we're on that old ball tour and stuff
doing those like arenas
she would wear fishnet tights with
fucking like
jeans as soon as it's a dress
it's trying to be sexy yes but if i wear
jean shorts and fishnets like
i get to be the cool girl because it's
shorts like none of it even makes any
sense i
i i'm so over it and like as long as i
feel comfortable if i
if my if my nipples are showing i'm not
wearing a bra and i was like my nipples
might come through i'm like
i do it's not because i'm like trying to
get something it's just my fucking but i
just so let me tell you something let me
tell you something you're not trying to
get something because you already have
it
you already have it all you can fucking
date guys there's these are actually
fake nebula
are they but also one more thing to me
the only thing i ascertained when i was
like let's not do sexy
or by that i mean anything that's going
to make you think
while you're on camera taylor swift i
i've named
her i she's my obsession with her it
knows no bounds it's
really really not it's i have finally
accepted about myself and i'm getting
honest about it and like
i want to be more really emily same page
wait you guys are swifties too
i was just saying i don't have any
swifty friends i need more like i have
communities online
benton like gets the merch like me too
or anyone
i like what i know about taylor swift is
like why i love this person so much i
think there's no one's ever spoken to me
in in a way that this artist has
she gets to wear glitzy glam she i love
that
i was on the phone taylor swift the
other day i wasn't no i'm not friends
with her i don't want to
i don't want to know her the
expectations are too high and she if
if she as much as like i think she
rolled her eyes at me or like
if i think that i've upset her in any
way i won't be able to listen to music
and i literally could die because that's
how much her music means to me
emotionally like it helps me
it helps my depression it helps my
anxiety like i need her in a way that
like
it feels weird saying that about an
artist like i watched billy eilish's
documentary
and i remember like girls being like you
saved my life billy and i'm just like
easy when but i really then i go oh my
god taylor's what just literally saved
my life
i remember someone else when she dies
and i literally was like
if taylor swift like they're like
what what like they said they were like
what if something happened to her there
was some kind of joke of like
man let's and i go i don't know what i
do i honestly i'm so grateful that i
have such a catalog to
like but i'm stealing myself for a like
when her it was released that red was
going to be
coming out november 19th i was like
survive until november
like i literally said that to myself i'm
like you have to be like watch
across the street better because it just
means i picked the best artist to love
by the way because she's so more
prolific than any other artist and it's
not because
she wants a lot of attention it's
because she's a genius and can't stop
writing she's like lennon mccartney
levels of genius and
anyone who wants to argue about and i'm
a huge beatles fan
grew up with the beatles taylor swift
you don't need to argue for taylor swift
being
the one of the greatest artists of all
time not
not possibly i would say the best artist
of all time best songwriter
best performer best uh tour fans i'm
learning so much about from her studying
her of how to
connect with your fans because i'm like
why do i feel like this person's my
sister and i don't know her and it's
because she has done the work
she's been calculated enough to make her
fans feel loved in a real genuine way
she knows she knows that it's all about
the fans but i am like now my tour i'm
like
i want to make it like a taylor swift
concert like i want my fans to like i
will be playing
the entire time in lip syncing
i want to have lights i want to have
beautiful sets that evoke whatever kind
of
imagery i want i want to have prizes i
want to have confetti or i want
something tangible that people can take
with them
i want a fan experience i want i want
why does stand-up touch have to be a
microphone and a fucking curtain
i want music cues when i did the um mtv
awards i got to like
do a monologue which was just stand up
but then i was like it would be funny if
there was like a light queue for this
and i was like
why have i never thought to put like use
in stand-up it makes it funny here's
what i'll say
because everyone's going to fuck it up
just that i understand that i'm getting
headsets for my tour i'm like
it's going to tell us thousands of
dollars we have to move with you yeah
you are going to lose money on the store
but
like my new the tour i'm doing in the
fall is called the touch me tour because
i did start to
after shows i always take pictures from
the stage but then also
when i run out now i always will just
run i don't run out
like with a screen i'd like just run
through the audience and like sit on
their laps and like in like crowd surf
to the stage and i just was like i just
like doing this it makes me i like to
like see i'm worried for your meet and
greets with the touch me tour though
yeah it's it's well i kind of do like
from the stage and i come out it's okay
um i'll have a hologram or whatever um
and uh
and my robot it might be my robot
something like that mine's called i'd
rename my
don't touch me so i'm going piggybacking
off of yours
and it's it's also honest but i will not
be going out in the crowd
and i mean no no i love touching your
face i touch myself
yeah it's true um but no i love touching
fans people are always like you don't
want a picture i'm like
no just post it they paid money to come
see me
i already trust them i know i do if
you're if you fuck with me
i fuck with you that's why i call my
there are a lot of comedians that are
like
that and and when people like security
guards that are with me they're like i
can't believe you like
hug your fans this time i'm like what
are you talking about oh my god the fact
that people go to perform in front of
their fans like get away from me no no
like
like no you bring them you hate your
fans i'm like
anyone that like bought my book or
listen to my i was wearing the merch
i used to like my fans until i got
honest because now they used to not like
the person they used to like the
presentation the sarah silverman
impression i was doing on stage and this
is like not until the past probably like
seven or eight years that i'm like and
now i don't
lie i'm so if you like me now i
i'm obsessed with you you're my best
that's why i call my podcast listeners
my besties and it's like
and i trust your choices i talk to them
i
really do trust them like a best friend
and i feel seen like them and i feel
like they can forgive me like a best
friend i can make mistakes i can have
that's right
my podcast i do it four days a week uh
yesterday i was having a very anxious
day because i had a
a shoot to do where i was going to see
someone that was very triggering and i
was freaking i was on my podcast i was
like
that and that's fucked up that i was
like so angry and i go guys
i'm having a really bad day and i can't
tell you about it because it's
not something i will tell you about when
i'm ready but i
i'm a bitch today and i was ru there's
been days when i've been so
like the worst person and and it's
embarrassing i'm i go
like skip today's podcast i'll literally
tell them and i'll go and then i issue a
statement the next morning being like i
was a bitch yesterday
because they're my friends if they don't
buy but this is what you're showing
exactly what and you would never fuck
with me anyway if it was only under the
conditions that i was perfect all the
time yes
um but also you uh what you're doing is
you're also giving people
being of service as part of the reason
that like when famous people like i
can't go to 12 step means i'm famous i'm
like no bitch you
have to go even harder because you are
so selfish because you know someone in
that meeting
is gonna go i was gonna fucking walk out
here i didn't i don't have time for this
however
this guy's here if this guy's here yes
but when you when you have a problem
like that like i'm really angry and i'm
just taking on the wrong things like
oh even someone in therapy even someone
who's like really successful like
even oh that's all i wanted when i was
in high school was for jennifer aniston
to tell me that she kind of hated
herself too
oh what oh you thought i would be
friends with you oh
well all right that is so fucking funny
just do this a lot oh and just and the
more she messes up her hair the better
it looks
yeah yeah it always i mean like that
hair her uh
hairline is fucking amazing oh the um
what's it called living proof living
proof i just got that yeah
the leave-in conditioner is fucking
amazing and i know her
so i i don't even tell her that i use it
and i have the dry shampoo in my bag and
when i go to our house i take it out of
my bag because i don't want her to think
i'm
i i literally use it because it's a
fucking other hairstylist use it on me
yes yes i just got it too and i felt
like are you buying this because of
anderson i'm like yeah i am because i
also
see i i'll do anything she does i like
it and then i pretend i don't use it
because i don't want her to think that
i'm like big fan
like i'm just like right it is a fucking
good product and i don't want you to
think i use it
why do i not like why do i want like
like that is weird yeah like that would
be a compliment to her yeah by the way
and
she's like she we've been friends for a
long time it's like she's not all of a
sudden be like
oh whitney is a fan like i'm insulting
her by thinking she would say no i
wouldn't think that
oh what oh no
that's you can have a bottle we have
with some in the take some
i don't care who wants a cocktail i just
didn't see i just like can't wait for
her to offer me a margarita i'll be like
i'll fall off the wagon for you bitch
let's do it
that is so go to casa vegas yes i don't
know do you still go there that was
there that's really that was
like 15 years ago the idea of that that
this is so something i would do that
you're sober except for one person
yeah so i so if i had both i don't drink
but
only with this one person i have
margaritas because i don't i want them
to think we're like and then anywhere
else
oh my god i'm gonna do that aniston
that's mine
that to me is more codependence relapse
than alcohol relax
that's not an alcohol relapse that's a
codependent relapse yeah
uh i i honestly might make that
exception i probably do anything she
tells me to do i've won this podcast
um it is your show now i love
it and i'm so frustrated that we have to
stop i mean this is crazy how long this
has been it's time not really we've been
talking off camera for about two hours
okay that's not true and i do have this
ability to make two hours feel like six
hours
ago that's six hour one i just went
through it did
you dig what are they talking about
there that was insane
i want to talk to you about so many i
love you and you know that i have so
many yeah
yes and you know that i end these
awkwardly my podcast is the nikki laser
podcast and i just want to say about
that is like
just like your podcast just jump in i
think a lot of people like don't
like do podcasts because they go oh
there's this is episode 137 i got to
listen it's like
just you'll catch up to all that yeah
yeah you can go back to good ones wait
wait where you like the description
just jump in tomorrow and join us
subscribe and then unsubscribe if you
don't like it
it's okay let's go i love you man i love
you don't write elephants
um listen to this show uh i'm obsessed
with you i'm obsessed with you fboy
island
oh yeah when does it come out uh end of
july fuck we didn't even get to talk
about f-boys don't
oh no next time
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign